[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour une
après midi consacrée à l'événement phare
de la semaine au sénat les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
on va vous faire vivre tout cela jusqu'à
16h30 avec nos journalistes
steve jourdain dans l'hémicycle va
suivre et analyser les questions alors
qu'y at-il au menu steve en parlera
crise sanitaire évidemment et
confinement avec cette question qui veut
paraître théorique mais qui en fait très
pratique qu'est ce qu'un commerce
essentiel le gouvernement devra y
répondre d'ici une heure maintenant et
on va en parler dans un mouvement
également sur ce plateau avec nous aussi
alexandre poussard il va recueillir
toutes les réactions des sénateurs et
des ministres alors un aperçu de vos
invités alexandre mais bien tarn
on parlera par exemple des différents
couacs du gouvernement dans le pilotage
de ce nouveau confinement
on en parlera avec le rapporteur du
projet de loi état d'urgence sanitaire
ici au sénat philippe bas à tout à
l'heure à l'excès andré puis le streamer
politique jean maillet sera en direct
avec nous pour nous transmettre les
réactions et les interrogations de sa
communauté sur twitter alors jean qu'est
ce que tu attends de cet après midi et
bien ce que j'en attends tams et surtout
de voir ce que les internautes vont
penser de ce débat actuellement très
tendues entre les sénateurs et le
gouvernement sur fond de reconfirme en
petit commerce utile pas utile qu'on
verra à tout à leur joie dans une
demi-heure notre face à face qui va
opposer le sénateur et l'air cédric
perrin et le socialiste et yannick
vaugrenard
on parlera politique internationale on
va revenir sur la présidentielle
américaine mais aussi sur l'attentât de
vienne l'autriche après la france est
saisie d'horreur après cet attentat
islamiste qui a causé la mort de quatre
personnes
mais d'abord une nuit de pagaille à
l'assemblée nationale les oppositions
étaient très remontés et les députés lrm
trop peu nombreux résultat les
républicains ont réussi à faire passer
un amendement prévoyant de prolonger
l'état d'urgence jusqu'au 14 décembre au
lieu du 7 février comme le voulait le
gouvernement
on va revenir sur ce coup de théâtre
avec nos invités sur ce plateau le
président du groupe r des pays le groupe
de la majorité présidentielle ici au
sénat françois patriarche ou bonjour et
également avec nous le sénateur et l'ère
de la haute loire laurent duplomb
bonjour bonjour on va en parler dans un
instant après le résumé de cette nuit
compliquée avec jeremy hunt semaine il
est adopté
nouveau revers pour l'exécutif hier soir
les députés d'opposition ont fait voter
par l'assemblée une prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 14
décembre et non jusqu'à mi-février comme
souhaité par le gouvernement
une surprise rendue possible par la
majorité elle même ses députés étant
trop peu nombreux dans l'hémicycle
dans la foulée un nouvel amendement et
même adopté il soumet à l'accord du
parlement
le renouvellement du confinement au delà
du 30 novembre le camouflet de trop pour
olivier veyrat
c'est un la réalité lanzhou vie d'au
moins 4 1 de débattre de sujets alors
que nous soyons pas de confort et de vie
de cette manière là comme topito c'est
nouveau les valeurs tarder s'organiser
réponse cinglante de l'opposition vos
propos étaient indignes et vous avez été
indigne c'est insupportable c'est le
ministre le chantage que vous êtes en
train de nous faire nous avons le droit
et nous allons continuer de critiquer
vos décisions parce que la démocratie
cela fonctionne comme cela que ça vous
plaise ou non
une colère partagée par la majorité
sénatoriale selon elle le débat
démocratique doit avoir lieu il faut qu
olivier ferrand qui a été député
comprennent bien que c'est pas seulement
en culpabilisant les députés et les
sénateurs qu'il va arriver à faire
passer ses messages et la question des
délais est une question essentielle on
peut pas on peut pas imaginer qu'on ne
dépasse pas d'une nouvelle prolongation
du confinement ou qu'on ne débatte pas
au parlement de la date de la fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire à l'assemblée
olivier ferrand a demandé la réserve des
votes sur les articles restent en
remettant les scrutins au moment choisi
par le gouvernement
l'exécutif pourrait également demander
une nouvelle délibération sur les deux
amendements adoptés hier soir votre
réaction
françois patriat cette situation on voit
une nuit très compliqué à l'assemblée
nationale la majorité n'arrive pas à
rassembler en nombre suffisant alors
qu'il ya un texte aussi majeur débattu
dans l'hémicycle
il ya deux choses le fond et la forme le
fond si l'objet pendant qu'on explique
quel est l'intérêt de raccourcir
aujourd'hui dans l'état de gravité où
nous sommes sanitairement de racour scié
aujourd'hui l'urgence alité single us de
revenus que ces mecs-là leur affirmer c
est un beau nom mais là c'était ramener
au 14 décembre qu est l un de quel est l
intérêt alors qu'il était fixé ou
toujours le raccourcir quand tu veux le
gouvernement pourquoi le raccourcir
alors qu'on est en train de dire aux
français attention la situation grave
c'est sur l'offre le fond sur la forme
j'entends bien que les députés n'aient
pas été assez présent c'est une faute
la majorité il appartient au groupe de
régler ce problème aujourd'hui dans une
situation aussi grave les parlementaires
doivent être aussi présent pour assurer
le soutien à la politique du
gouvernement une politique courageuse et
qui ne tourne pas comme on dit mais qui
réagit au coup par coup par rapport à la
situation
stabilité de christophe castaner no 4 et
hommes passaient pas christophe en
lui-même je te faut lui même il est prêt
dans le groupe il est présent là bas il
a été en quarantaine est là aujourd'hui
c'est le sait les députés eux-mêmes qui
l'aura mais consciente d'être là c'est
tout votre réaction laurent duplomb cas
le symbole quand même d'avoir recours on
l'entend à cette procédure
la réserve de vote utilisé très rarement
c'est à dire que les députés vont voter
sur un texte sur lequel le gouvernement
va choisir de garder les amendements
qu'il veut alors qu'on est dans cette
situation on attendrait peut-être une
union de national autour de l'état
d'urgence bah je pense pas que ce soit
un problème d'union nationale est par
contre je pense exactement inverse de ce
que vient de dire monsieur patriat
je pense qu'au contraire si on veut
respecter le parement il faut lui donner
des dates des dates qui correspondent à
des décisions qui ont été prises au
départ le président de la république a
annoncé un confrère confinement de
quatre semaines je vois pas pourquoi on
donnerait un blanc seing pour aller
jusqu'à après 2 c'est le cas du rejet de
ce profil quand le gouvernement a voulu
que le sénat se prononce rapidement sur
des textes importants
le sénat l'a fait et parfois même au pas
de charge pas la semaine dernière à un
moment donné je pense qu'il est normal
au vu des tensions que nous avons dans
notre pays
au vu des difficultés que nous pouvons
rencontrer que le parlement soit à sa
juste valeur et qu'au fur et à mesure de
l'avancement du temps ils puissent
véritablement non seulement être
informés jouer son rôle de contrôle et
avoir à voter des décisions en temps
réel et je trouve que la bce
la proposition du 14 décembre me va très
bien
le parlement est il en jambe et est ce
que si le risque concours françois
patriat
dans cette séquence écoutez je suis sam
ancien parlementaire pour vous dire que
ces situations je les ai toujours connu
là je parle de la responsabilité je
crois qu'on sait ce qu'est ce que est ce
que l'opposition est là pour critiquer
proposer ce qui est son rôle
ceux qui sont de voir ou bien pour
ajouter de la difficulté à la difficulté
or aujourd'hui tu aimais bien entendu
question mais bien celui que si parce
que vous mettez en fait sans heurts mais
vous mettez aujourd'hui le père
vous mettez à jour vos personnels
hospitaliers en difficulté le fait de
voter personnel bien sûr que le bien que
le gouvernement va le réparer
heureusement quand on fait des bêtises
et l'irresponsabilité amoureux de
position je pense qu'ils les
responsabilités rajouter de la
difficulté est là dans ce futur ça n'est
pas responsable pour ces années sans
réponse est trop facile de dire c'est de
l'irresponsabilité il y aurait les bons
et les mauvais non là respect du
parlement est le respect il ya ceux il
ya ceux qui gèrent l'action c'est qu'ils
font de la politique ceux qui sont élus
par le pied à ceux qui jeunes qui sont
faits par le peuple sait les députés et
les sénateurs fait jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les ministres ne le sont pas
et j'ai bien normal qu'à chaque décision
qui engendre autant autant de crispation
et autant de questions des français il
est bien normal qu'à chaque décision
le parlement puisse être consulté dans
son rôle de contrôle mais aussi dans son
rôle de pouvoir donner des décisions
concrètes comme celle ci de reconduire
l'état d'urgence pourquoi vous craignez
le fait c'est de reposer cette question
pour l'inter de reconduire sénat
d'argent ça près de 14 de ses latéraux
sam usher sénateurs je crains que dans
huit jours vous en soyez amené à
regretter vos propos comme aujourd'hui
où pouvaient regretter votre vote du 12
octobre vous demandiez à l'époque la
rouverture des discothèques des bars des
restaurants
votez ici dans le sénat irresponsabilité
le 12 octobre la majorité la majorité du
sénat les républicains et les
socialistes ont voté un amendement
disant qu'il fallait rouvrir les
discothèques
alors qu'on le sait bien qu'avec
dangereux vous serez amené de la même
façon regretter vos propos d'aujourd'hui
je suis prêt et je suis pas sûr que sur
la durée
les français jugent aussi durement ce
que vous êtes en train de dire
il vous faut rien de bien faire
attention de le dire comme ça parce que
des fois la rose or pour est arrosé on
va continuer à faire des réactions
autour et bien de ce sujet qu on le voit
est vraiment infâme inflammable on va
rejoindre alexandre poussard salle des
conférences pour une autre réaction
celle de fabien gay sénateur communiste
de la seine saint denis alexandre et oui
fabien gay qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ce que vient de dire à l'instant
françois patriat les parlementaires
d'opposition qui demande au gouvernement
de revenir en décembre pour prolonger
des mesures sanitaires
est ce que ces parlementaires sont
irresponsables non je ne le crois pas
nous nous penchons et nous l'avons dit
depuis le début que le parlement doit
être associé à cette gestion de crise
par exemple il est quand même
inconcevable que le premier ministre
vienne ici demander un vote de confiance
et nous dise pour la stratégie d'euros
confinement je ne vous en dirais pas
plus ça sera dans deux heures dans une
conférence de presse
ça ce n'est pas admissible et ça c'est
irresponsable lorsqu'on me demande
l'unité de la nation
il faut associer le parlement c'est tout
ce que demandent les parlementaires de
l'opposition mais aussi la majorité
nous devons construire les solutions
ensemble depuis le mois de mars nous
sommes dans un état d'urgence sanitaire
quasi permanent est en fait le
gouvernement considère que le parlement
est un empêcheur de tourner en rond et
il serait un ralentisseur alors que
justement le parlement peut apporter des
solutions et fait partie d'une des clés
de la réussite de cette sortie de crise
sanitaire social et économique donc il
faut qu'il y ait un échange permanent
une co-construction de permanente et il
n'est pas fou ou anodin de revenir
régulièrement vers le parlement pour
co-construire les choses qu'est ce que
vous pensez des différents couacs ont
connu ces derniers jours dans le captage
de cette crise sanitaire on l'a vu hier
soir à l'assemblée nationale avec et
bien l'absence d'une majorité
présidentielle on l'a vu également avec
l' annonce d'un couvre-feu à paris
finalement démentie par matignon il ya
un problème de pilotage de cette crise
oui et puis vous pourrez en rajouter
beaucoup la question des masques on
disait au mois de mars que ça ne servait
à rien de les mettre et aujourd'hui vous
êtes pénalisé 235 euros
on a dit pendant des semaines et des
semaines que les enfants il ne fallait
pas leur mettre un masque et aujourd'hui
deux jours avant la rentrée nous avons
appris que même les enfants de 6 ans qui
allait rentrer en cp devait porter un
masque et beaucoup de choses comme ça on
est ministre du tourisme nous a dit
partez en vacances puis on a vécu un
confinement
donc la question c'est que les
françaises et les français n'ont pas
besoin d'être infantilisés ils ont
besoin qu'on leur parle clair leur dire
voilà la situation dans laquelle on est
voilà des décisions que nous allons
prendre si la situation empire voilà les
décisions que nous devrons prendre et si
nous sommes à un niveau très haut de
saturation nos lits d'hôpitaux peut-être
que nous ouvrons ont confiné total il
faut parler caire et données de
l'ensemble des éléments
pour que une acceptabilité des décisions
prises elles doivent être claires et
lisibles et arrêter de tergiverser
un mot également sur la fermeture des
commerces non essentiel pendant se
reconfigurer une fermeture qui provoque
une fronde de certains élus locaux qui
sont très attachés à leurs commerces de
proximité mais le gouvernement jean
castex persiste et signe
pour l'instant les commerces restent
fermés mais là aussi ils ont raison
parce que là pour que ça soit une
acceptabilité donc je parle il faut que
ça soit clair pourquoi les rayons des
hypermarchés pourraient donner vendre
des livres plutôt que de laisser ouvrir
les libraires et la seule réponse du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire b du coup on
ne vendra plus de livres nulle part seul
le e-commerce dont amazon que je ne veux
pas fustiger mais qui déjà pratiquer
l'optimisation fiscale et la fraude
fiscale avec nous le non paiement de la
tva sur les revendeurs c'est une
question et je le dis il ya une question
démocratique qui aujourd'hui peut dire
qu'un livre et non essentiel de la
culture est essentielle et encore plus
aujourd'hui
au moment où nous vivons en confinement
donc là il ya une question qui peut
décider qu est ce qui est l'essentiel ou
pas c'est une vocation
mais cette fermeture des commerces non
essentiels occupera cette séance de
questions d'actualité merci bonjour
alexis commerçants ils ont déjà souffert
beaucoup de la première crise il
faudrait pas qu'ils les anchois ceux qui
payent la deuxième crise
merci beaucoup fabien gay dans votre vie
si alexandre une réaction je voulais
juste dire en deux mots ce qui est
important dans le contrôle du parlement
et du fait qu'ils soient associés dans
les décisions qui sont prises c'est
qu'on est sur des sujets qui sont des
privations de liberté ces sujets de
privation de liberté
c'est à nous de nous en préoccuper la
séparation des pouvoirs fait que le
parlement est dans son rôle quand il
vérifie quand il contrôle et quand ils
acceptent certaines formes de privation
de liberté mais je trouve qu'il est tout
à fait normal qu'ils soient non
seulement associés et que les choses
soient faites de façon les plus la plus
la plus réglementaire possible et la
plus sectionné possible pour répondre à
mon collègue du plomb
tout l'été les deux tiers des français
pensent que le gouvernement ne va pas
assez loin en matière de prévention
liberté
les deux tiers des français le pont
donc voilà la réponse à vous donc je ne
pense pas avec 2,6 et qu'il le pense
dans les sondages
si la tendance est une vrai quoi d'autre
ne sais pas si tu réponds c'est un
sondage non non pas s'occuper des six
qui a pas de moi je suis pas élu pour
affronter soit très loin et vous pensé
pour votre loi privation de liberté vous
le dites comme tel vous pensez sabots
dit si le président va trop loin sur les
privations de liberté jeudi que les
privations de liberté sont un élément
essentiel de notre contrôle
il faut qu'on contrôle pour voir si les
privations de liberté ne vont pas trop
loin ou pas c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs et je pense que là dessus on
devrait les français d'accord devant les
français parce que mon passé loin à
l'est ce débat au parlement tout car
fait aussi la situation dans le reste du
pays et notamment et bien la rébellion
des commerçants de proximité de nombreux
élus locaux les soutiennent et défis
l'exécutif le gouvernement lui reste
droit dans ses bottes confirme la
fermeture des commerces mais aussi des
rayons non essentiels on n'a pas dans un
instant après ce rappel de la situation
avec pierre-henri holder boom le
mal-être s'affiche sur les vitrines des
commerçants
depuis plusieurs jours les arrêtés se
multiplient à travers la france pourrait
ouvrir les commerces de proximité
il faut qu'on se mobilise aujourd'hui
pour nos petits commerces si demain
n'existeront plus devais m'inscrire dans
la démarche qui a été engagée à dijon
qui a été engagée à bonn qui a été
engagée à chalon sur saône dans d'autres
grandes villes et je m'inscris dans
cette démarche là la démocratie aussi
doit venir des territoires et des choses
ne peuvent pas être imposés comme ça
administrativement par le gouvernement
lundi le ministre de l'économie bruno le
maire dénoncé le comportement
irresponsable de ces mères le premier
ministre jean castex lui surenchérit
hier à l'assemblée nationale
car la république est confronté à la
plus grave crise sanitaire qu'elle ait
subie depuis des décennies on n'appelle
pas les mères serviteur d'allah
blick a violé les lois de la république
ça n'est pas possible pour éviter
l'inégalité entre les supermarchés les
petits commerces
l'association des maires de france
propose de nouvelles mesures de sécurité
sanitaire il faut durcir les normes
d'accès dans les grandes surfaces c'est
à dire avoir des jauges qu'ils soient
effectivement respectées hauteur par
exemple de 10 mètres carrés minimum par
personne m d'ailleurs les mêmes jauge
les mêmes nord dont les petits commerces
de proximité à savoir que à commerce ne
doit pas pouvoir accueillir plus d'une
personne par 10 mètres carrés face à la
colère des commerçants
le gouvernement a annoncé la fermeture
de plusieurs rayons dans les
supermarchés comme les jouets
l'électroménager les produits culturels
et les fleurs et nous ont rejoints en
visio qu'ovide oblige pour ce débat
jacques creyssel bonjour vous êtes
délégué général de la fédération du
commerce et de la distribution merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous et également
avec nos philippe moati
bonjour vous êtes rigaud nomistes
professeur à l'université paris 7 et
coprésident de l'observatoire société
consommation l'aube soko merci beaucoup
première question pour vous jacques
creyssel et commerçants craignent d'être
les sacrifiés de se confiner dans sont
ils réellement plus fragile que lors du
premier confinement qu'est ce que vous
demandez vous maintenant au gouvernement
avec une version vraiment le sentiment
d'être effectivement les victimes de se
re confinement la première fois tout le
monde était arrêté pour de bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons certains s'étaient
arrêtés de même comme dans le btp
aujourd'hui on a dit aux industriels
repartez doit travailler aux bâtiments
aux travaux publics
allez-y et finalement les seuls à qui on
a dit s'arrêter ce sont les commerçants
en plus novembre à décembre ce sont les
moi essentiel de l'année pour beaucoup
de commerces
ça n'est pas la même chose qu'en mars et
puis enfin il faut bien avoir conscience
que c'est la troisième année de suite
que c'était la plus importante de
l'année est mise entre parenthèses vous
avez les gilet jaune il ya deux ans les
manifestations contre les retraites qui
ont bloqué les centres-villes l'année
dernière et puis cette fois-ci là que
vide et donc pour beaucoup de commerces
et notamment le petit commerce est une
catastrophe
alors la solution qui a été retenue par
le gouvernement pour nouvelle est
perdant perdant puisque en fait en
fermant un certain nombre de rayons on
n'a pas amélioré la situation du petit
commerce
on les met dans les mains des amazones
on a fait en sorte que les français n'y
comprennent plus rien on a nous des
dizaines de milliers de salariés qui
vont se retrouver en chômage partiel et
on a les fournisseurs notamment français
les pme qui vont se retrouver en très
grande difficulté un pense aux problèmes
des sapins de noël de l'horticulture du
linge de maison dans tous ces domaines
là et donc ce nous ce que nous disons et
dont le dit je crois avec les petits
class c'est ce qu'on disait moi j'ai
longuement vu le premier métier sur le
sujet à plusieurs reprises ce week-end
c'est ce qu'il faut autoriser c'est une
réouverture progressive par exemple sur
rendez vous des petits commerces prendre
toute une qu'un cocktail de mesures de
façon à ce que on puisse progressivement
non pas revenir à une vie normale et à
mai à une situation qui permette aux
commerces de continuer à exister parce
que c'est essentiel parce que s'il n'y a
plus de commerce il n'y a plus de villes
dans notre pays il n'ya plus d'emploi
non plus on est le premier employeur
privé de france il faut toujours aussi
s'en souvenir
nous avons des discussions j'en ai
d'ailleurs avec bruno le maire
en sortant de cette émission de façon à
faire en sorte que à partir du 12
novembre
comme l'annoncé le président république
et le premier ministre nous puissions
commencer à repartir sur des bases qui
soit plus positive
naturellement tout ceci dépend militaire
film en est il dans quel état les
commerces de proximité sont ils sortis
du premier confinement comment s'est
comportée bien le consommateur français
et comment est ce qu'on le voit commencé
à se comporter alors de cette deuxième
vague
il faut distinguer le commerce
alimentaire de commerce non alimentaire
puisque lors du premier confinement la
frontière et était nette
1 il n'y avait pas de discussion sur ce
qui était essentiel et ce qui ne l'était
pas manifestement ce qui était
l'essentiel c'était c'était la santé de
l'alimentation et l'hygiène tout
simplement et donc sur le secteur
alimentaire qui était en état de
fonctionnement le commerce de proximité
en a profité à la fois parce que parce
qu'on était entravé dans sa mobilité et
donc par définition la proximité et plus
proches mais aussi parce qu elle hilare
une sorte de réflexe citoyen beaucoup de
consommateurs en ont voulu à travers des
achats dans le commerce de proximité
témoigner de leur désir de soutenir un
petit commerce pour qu'on a reconnu
l'importance dans la vie quotidienne
d'autant plus qu'on était confinée à la
maison le commerce non alimentaire lui a
déjà énormément souffert et il faut
avoir conscience que le commerce non
alimentaire indépendant et à un secteur
très fragile comme ça a été rappelée à
l'instant on va rentrer dans une période
critique pour la réussite de l'année
ça fait 2 2 deux années consécutives que
cette période critique a été gâchée par
des événements exogènes donc ce commerce
qui est déjà très affaibli voit les
perspectives des prochaines semaines
avec un très très mauvais oeil donc il
ya vraiment un sujet je pense que c'est
là c'est le conflit dans lequel le
gouvernement ait pris 1
comment arriver à concilier les
considérations sanitaires avec les
considérations économiques et là très
clairement jeudi en région parisienne je
pense qu'à une forme d'incompréhension
le confinement actuelle n'est pas du
tout vécu comme le précédent on a le
sentiment que le on est pas on n'est pas
à l'arrêt on a vraiment on avait vu les
rues vides la fois précédente là on a le
sentiment quand même que on fonctionne
quasi normalement et donc du coup on ne
comprend plus pourquoi ces petits
commerces qui apporte tant est qu'ils
sont si fragiles et si nécessaire notre
économie à notre vie quotidienne
pourquoi ils ne sont pas en mesure de
fonctionner donc je pense qu'à une
incompréhension actuellement du côté des
consommateurs est certainement le
désirent à travers des comportements
d'achat d'apporter leur soutien à ces à
ces commerçants d'ailleurs on manque
encore de recul nouveau confinement dire
juste de démarrer mais je ne serais pas
étonné que les formules qui se met en
place rapidement quelques fois
d'ailleurs avec le soutien de la grande
distribution
ces formules de click and collect par
exemple je ne serais pas étonné car
rencontre un franc succès parce qu'elles
vont permettre aux consommateurs
d'exprimer des valeurs à travers leurs
mêmes comportements d'achat c'est
peut-être une piste un début de solution
françois patriat votre votre réaction à
ce que vient de nous dire philippe moity
bon je vais les commerces non
alimentaires type le mans la gym vous
dire les anciennes des choses
premièrement les premières victimes du
coc vide
ce ne sont pas les petits commerçants
ces 38 mille personnes déjà décédé ceux
qui vont encore baisser dès maintenant
tous aider kim 450 hier 500 par jour
peut-être plus la semaine prochaine
c'est ça les premières victimes et ça ça
nous ça doit nous ouvrir les yeux sur le
fait que ce que veut le gouvernement
dans ce confinement qui l'a voulu
alléger pour que
économique puisse se poursuivre par
ailleurs c'est de limiter les
déplacements
c'est clair bon alors j'entends bien et
je comprends les difficultés des petits
commerçants et je connais la réalité du
commerce de proximité
il n'empêche que personne ne parle du
plan mis en place par le gouvernement
15 milliards 15 milliards pour le petit
commerce et pm2 de proximité pour le
mois de novembre c'est autant que ce
qu'on a mis depuis le mois de mars 15
médias avec deux dans le fonds de
solidarité jusqu'à 10000 euros d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires avec dedans
l'exonération des cotisations sociales à
des deux dans une prise en charge de la
peau de loyer par ailleurs à côté avec
le clic clac le click and collect par le
click and collect pabr qui va être qui
va être maintenant généralisé et qui
sera du bonus pour ceux qui pourront le
faire aujourd'hui et la volonté
d'augmenter le commerce demain le
commerce en ligne de le faire donc il ya
des mesures
j'entends bien les difficultés mais je
connais je vois aussi demain le plan que
fut mis en place du gouvernement qui est
de nature à rassurer les petits
commerçants et leur permettent de passer
la crise très confiant de réaliser lui
locaux qui veulent prendre des arrêtés
justement pas partir dans les élus
locaux
trois choses la première chose ils
défient l'état de droit ils défient
l'état de droit cannois il a des filles
2 il incite les gens à bien la
désobéissance civique
3 il met en difficulté et en grande
difficulté le personnel hospitalier et
les hôpitaux ils ont une lourde
responsabilité
je rappelle les chiffres sur les 36000
communes en france où 35 milles et elle
calque il ya 71 merck a pris un arrêté
cl ont déjà retiré il en reste 55 ne
pensons pas que c'est une généralité et
je me suis élevé dès dimanche contre
l'attitude de ces mères qui incite les
commerçants à la désobéissance laurent
du point ce que vous vous soutenez ces
mères qui prennent ces arrêtés pour
permettre et bien à certains commerçants
de rester ouverts aujourd'hui je les
comprends je les comprends parce que je
pense que comment voulez vous que les
français comprennent les paradoxes qui
sont devant nos yeux
comment un français peut comprendre que
vous pouvez acheter des fleurs dans un
supermarché et que le fleuriste qui est
à deux pas de chez vous puis cette ferme
et comment on peut comprendre que dans
un supermarché c'est des centaines de
personnes qui sont et qui rentre et qui
est qu'ils en sortent mais si fine super
mary j
né dans les supermarchés pour
l'alimentation c'est christ devient
toujours rythmé non mes fleurs ses
filles que ça a été fermée flux vous
avez pris la décision les flux allait
fermer après les décisions des maires de
rester de laisser ouvert les petits
commerces
le fleuriste qui a deux personnes dans
son magasin il ya sûrement moins de
risques d'avoir une contamination du coc
vite que quand vous allez dans
l'intermarché
des centaines de personnes donc ces
paradoxes les français les comprennent
pas le même paradoxe où on nous dit 15
milliards d'euros 20 milliards le
premier ministre a dit dimanche soir 20
milliards d'euros pour les petits
commerces
nous serons à 3000 milliards de dette à
la fin de l'année 2010 pas leurs impôts
si si si on est prêt à temps donné 2
milliards pourquoi on laisse repartir
l'économie
pourquoi on bloque pas complètement le
confinement common mars parce que tout
simplement se rendent compte et tous les
français le comprennent que si l'on ne
veut pas continuer de creuser le trou
dans lequel on est en train de tomber
mais non vous demandez pas son goût même
façon que vous vous pouvez pas dire on
laisse l'économie journée et ne pas
regarder la réalité des choses
alors la proposition elle aurait été
simple c'est qu'il fallait faire un
protocole sanitaire ont fait un
protocole sanitaire qui est dans les
grandes surfaces le même que dans les
petits commerces et un déplacement chez
élémentaire ya passé les fêtes est comme
un chien dans les séries chez le
fleuriste et aux grands de la grande
surface mais il y aura deux déplacements
ça il sort bientôt déplaça ils sortent
bien d'hommes et pour ça il ya dehors
deux fois et en dehors là le risque si
on t'accuse importante de dents alors
ils resteront plus longtemps dans une
grande surface avec le risque de se
contaminer
est-ce que vous refusez c'est qu'il soit
sur le trottoir à l'extérieur pour aller
chez le fleuriste ça tient pas debout
nous parler des grandes surfaces les
grandes surfaces justement certaines il
a estimé avoir leur mot à dire regardez
bien ce que mes leclerc dans ses rayons
on peut lire regarder bien voilà cette
affiche nous fermons nos rayons non
alimentaires
d'après jean castex est mieux de
favoriser nos amis amazon et cdiscount
jacques creyssel qui va sortir pour vous
gagnon de tout cela amazon est ce que
vous estimez que eh bien tout cela au
final est en train de favoriser le géant
américain
alimentaire que l'on sait c'est que ceux
qui vont sortir perdant c'est le
commerce physique en général et qu'il
faut surtout cesser d'opposer les grands
et de ti notre problème en france
c'est de faire en sorte que nous
continuons à voir des grands des petits
commerces des grilles un commerce dans
nos villes aux alentours de nos villes
parce que ce sont eux qui sont
aujourd'hui le premier employeur privé
de france le commerce en france et 3
millions six cent mille emplois et à
chaque fois que on encourage amazon
comme c'est le cas et c'est tout à fait
clair on détruit de fête de l'emploi en
france et ont détruit nos villes donc
les choses sont tout à fait claires de
ce côté là il faut absolument faire en
sorte d'abord qu'on ait une vision
stratégique du commerce
et deuxièmement qu'on puisse rouvrir le
plus rapidement possible tout en étant
parfaitement conscients des deux ce qui
est dit à l'instant par monsieur patriat
nous sommes naturellement conscient des
problèmes sanitaires c'est pour ça qu'il
faut trouver des solutions adaptées en
sachant qu'il y a de grandes chances
qu'on soit dans cette situation pendant
de nombreuses semaines et que donc nous
ne pouvons vivre sans commerce
pendant plusieurs semaines ou plusieurs
mois donc il faut inventer un nouveau
modèle en tout cas amazon au niveau
mondial a bien profité de la crise
sanitaire on va regarder quelques
chiffres amazon a créé quatre cent mille
emplois dans le monde depuis le début
2020 et a fait + 38 de plus 38 % sur les
recettes tirées des ventes de ces
articles françois patriat
parce que voilà ces fermetures c'est pas
aussi une incitation à consommer en
ligne est ce que ça va pas favoriser
amazon qui on le voit avec ces chiffres
se porte déjà très bien bon pour qu
amazon fonctionne il faut qu'il dit
clients et si les gens veulent pas qu
amazon se développe non cap achetés sur
amazon mais pour un quart d'heure
d'échauffement
aujourd'hui ils ont trop chaud ils ont
des commerces de prison des commerces
j'allais dire il ya des grandes surfaces
de proximité où ils peuvent l'acheter
les éléments essentiels tu as des gamins
que le sens essentiel il peut le faire
par ailleurs donc l'angle peut pas faire
par ailleurs les magasins sont fermés
les gms donné que et il faut surtout la
réponse à cela les magasins du monde
vivent dans des taudis qui commanda les
voilà la réponse à cela c'est que demain
ce que fait le gouvernement des temps
100 millions aujourd'hui
pour permettre aux petits commerces de
développer le commerce virtuel et de le
faire et aussi de la même façon moi je
suis très content de ma je n'achète pas
sur amazon d'allergie à mon commerce
virtuel à côté de commander à moi mon co
notre proximité de commander le
jouer pour des petits enfants il en
reste il reste pas moins vrai que le
virtuel où le click and collect par
exemple pour 1 kw à force ça va être un
peu difficile alors qu'elle a ça va être
un peu compliqué c'est sûr que pendant
qu'on va faire c'est compliqué d'être
regardée à limoges par exemple damian
coeur mais pas chez amazon type on sait
pas quoi ces amazones
c'est le bronze savais pas quoi c'est
chamakh à l'image par exemple une
quarantaine de petits commerçants ont
monté en quelques jours leur plateforme
du commerce
ça va ouvrir demain ça va s'appeler
chapines limoges ça ça peut être la mine
soit laurent duplomb c'est ce que ça
peut être une solution dans une ville
comme limoges
moi je suis issue et élus dans un dans
une commune de 2600 habitants ses
préférences le click and collect peut se
faire sur une population de commerçants
jeunes qui ont l'habitude de travailler
avec internet et avec un système
informatique vous avez des commerçants
qui sont un peu plus âgés qui n'ont pas
cessé ces éléments là et qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi on les ferme de
faire une de façon administrative alors
qu'à côté de ça il y avait des rayons
qui étaient ouverts dans les gms et que
le fait que le gouvernement se soit
engouffrés dans le principe de tout
interdire
je ne pense pas que ce soit la meilleure
des solutions 1 philippe moati est ce qu
est ce que vous pensez de ce type
d'initiative à ce que ça peut marcher
pour vous c'est une initiative qui va
rester marginal ou est-ce que ça peut
être bien voilà l'avenir pour le
commerce en france c'est une
paradoxalement c'est une très bonne
chose
donc il est clair qu'à court terme c'est
amazon qui va tirer les marrons du feu
ça fait pas l'ombre d'un doute ça a déjà
été le cas lors du premier confinement
malgré les entraves dont le géant du
e-commerce a souffert donc ça va
continuer d'autant qu'on approche des
fêtes de fin d'année il rappela que
friday amazon à une étendue d'offres
considérable et une qualité de service
qui fait que même ceux qui ne m'aiment
pas achète chez lui mais en parallèle ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir les
initiatives de la grande distribution
qui font un peu la courte échelle aux
petits commerces de proximité pour
faciliter leur accès aux consommateurs
et sa mine de rien ça va permettre de
peut-être d'accélérer la constitution de
deux challenger de taille substantielle
pour pour contrer amazon parce que les
distributeurs français ont pris beaucoup
de retard dans la formation de leurs
places de marché et donc la mine de rien
la crise leur donne l'opportunité
d'accélérer cette dynamique et peut-être
qu'on verra émergents enfin les
challengers sérieux contre contre amazon
et puis les initiatives locales
qu'ils sont en train de se mettre en
place sont extrêmement intéressante là
aussi le commerce de proximité notamment
indépendants étaient en retard dans sa
numérisation donc mine de rien le sa
crise est en train de donner un coup
d'accélérateur la minéralisation du
commerce français y compris du commerce
indépendant
il faut simplement espérer que les
petites choses qui sont en train de se
faire ici s'agrègent parce que dans le
monde du e-commerce la taille est
extrêmement importante donc un acteur
comme la poste et est aujourd'hui un
soutien par rapport aux initiatives que
prennent les mairies il faut espérer que
voilà qu'on assiste à une association
des grands acteurs du commerce de la
techno de la logistique pour soutenir
cette initiative qui ont des racines
locales mais qui doivent s'appuyer sur
des ressources de dimension
internationale
comme j'habite et ce n'est pas forcément
une mauvaise chose françois patriat et
on entend aussi bien des voix 1 du côté
des politiques à droite comme à gauche
qui on demande carrément aux français de
ne pas avoir recours à amazon y compris
au niveau du gouvernement en écoutant
pas sur amazon amazon c'est la mort de
nos librairies et de notre vie de
quartier il faut pas que ce soit amazon
pour faire simple qui soit le grand
gagnant de cette crise au détriment des
commerces de proximité ou même
d'ailleurs des grandes surfaces dont je
rappelle qu'elle embauche des centaines
de milliers de personnes et qu'elles
sont vitales pour l'économie française
dont nous avions des propositions qui
avaient été portées par l'association
des maires de france il ya déjà quelque
temps la taxation de la livraison
puisque en réalité cette livraison
elle est indispensable à l'activité
d'entreprises comme amazon ou d'autres c
est me semble-t-il une piste
intéressante mais malheureusement qui
n'a pas été suffisamment explorées
françois patriat ce que vous dites comme
anne hidalgo comme philippe laurent
comme bruno le maire n'achetez pas sur
amazon aujourd'hui les duels tout à
l'heure je les dis donc je ne viens pas
évident à moins possible le moins
possible du moins possible mais il
n'empêche que le commerce en ligne
inexorablement la génération qui nous
suit et l'autre génération utilisent de
plus en plus il faut s'adapter non pas
en allant chez amazon faisait en sorte
que le commerce nat nord fait en france
celui de proximité le petit commerce
moyens commerces puissent y accéder
aujourd'hui
mais quand on parle tout à l'heure de
problèmes aux tigres en plomb entre
rencontrées par les entreprises
avouez que les mesures prises par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui pour que ces
commerçants puissent faire à leur charge
face à leurs charges avec la suppression
des cotisations sociales avec le prise
en charge de leur chiffre d'affaires
avec le clic et au legs qui vient plus
écouté sur les mesures permettent qui
permettront aux petits commerces je
pense du passé où aller pour conclure je
voudrais qu'on en revienne et bien un
petit peu sur ce que vous évoquez au
début de ce débat
l'acceptation de ce reconfirme ans alors
si on regarde et bien un sondage
paradoxa denso consulting 7 français sur
10 à des rehaussements finement mais
notez également que seulement 1 51% des
français sont convaincus par le discours
la semaine dernière d'emmanuel macro et
54 % des français pensent que le
président de la république sait où il va
donc il ya une espèce de quand même de
paradoxes de dichotomie laurent duplomb
parce qu'on peut l'expliquer finalement
les gens disent on doit bien pouvoir se
recombiner puisqu'on n'a pas tellement
le choix mais on a l'impression que le
gouvernement navigue à vue
la vie
as vu ça on l'a vu depuis le début après
moi j'ai pas de jets potes de gêne pas à
commenter les sondages les choses elles
sont ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
si ça se trouve dans deux jours on
reposerait la même question il pourrait
y avoir une réponse totalement
différente
donc non je pense que là où on a besoin
de retrouver un peu de confiance et un
peu de cohésion
c'est dans l'es6 ion dans les décisions
qui sont prises et les décisions qui
sont prises dans l'amendement qui
avaient été portées par le sénat sur la
l'ouverture des petits commerces
le principe il était de laisser la
possibilité au préfet d'autoriser dans
les départements dont il pensait que ça
puisse être fait les ouvertures de ces
petits commerces de proximité
je pense que de vouloir faire du
jacobinisme et de bloquer la vue le
système par plaisir de bloquer de façon
identique la totalité de la france n'est
pas une forme moderne de faire de la
politique et n'est surtout pas la
meilleure des solutions pour régler le
problème de l est le mot de la fin pour
jacques creyssel puisque vous avez dit
vous allez voir bruno le maire après
cette émission qu'elle est vouée bien
demandé au ministre de l'économie dans
cette situation et d'un très compliqué
pour les commerces aujourd'hui je vais
d'abord lui demander de penser à tout ce
dont on n'a pas parlé c'est à dire les
trente et quelques % de français qui
maîtrise mal internet les 1 à 2 millions
d'interdît bancaire
il faut qu'on ait des solutions qui
puissent bénéficier à tous et pour cela
il faut permettre dans le respect
maximum des règles sanitaires à une
réouverture de l'ensemble des commerces
non alimentaires dans vraiment avec des
conditions adaptées
ça me paraît totalement indispensables
notamment avant noël elles sont pas
dépendants de la merci merci beaucoup à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat merci
laurent duplomb françois patriat cela
vous laisse aller philippe moati
nous sommes maintenant à 25 minutes des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
qu'on va vous faire vivre tout cet après
midi avec nos journalistes alexandre
poussard qui est toujours salle des
conférences on va également avoir le
streamer politique jean mathieu qui va
nous donner toutes les réactions de sa
communauté sur cette plateforme twitch
et puis steve jourdain dans l'hémicycle
du sénat que pouvez-vous nous dit
ir du menu des questions d'actu steve ou
alors au delà des couacs en matière de
communication de la part du gouvernement
de la déco est plus politique
on l'a vu avec ce coup de théâtre hier à
l'assemblée nationale on se demandera
ici cet après-midi qu'est ce qu'un
commerce est essentielle
on l'a vu sur votre plateau tout le
monde n'est pas forcément d'accord sur
cette question il ya eu les polémiques
sur les librairies les polémiques sur
les coiffeurs à domicile et sur les
fleuristes ici aussi les sénateurs vont
à nouveau interpellé le gouvernement sur
ce point
sur le terrain on le sait la fed à la
fronde des élus locaux
je poursuis vous l'avais dit à mme tout
à l'heure plusieurs maires ont pris des
arrêtés pour permettre à ces petits
commerces est bien d'ouvrir de continuer
à rester ouverts le petit commerce un
sujet typiquement sénatoriales hans
hamel plusieurs choses ça mais le
plusieurs thèmes se mêlent la défense
des territoires saml la défense des
communes semaine également à la défense
de la ruralité plusieurs questions
seront posées sur ce thème il y aura des
questions des communistes des
socialistes des centristes mais aussi
des questions sur ce thème de la part
des républicains c'est hatem trans
partisan ici au sénat le gouvernement va
donc devoir répondre aux sénateurs en
essayant d'éviter les petits
cafouillages constatée ces dernières
heures la séance promet d'être très
agitée terme d'une séance très agitée
qu'on va à suivre maintenant dans 23
minutes très exactement vous retrouvera
à ce moment là steve on va maintenant
s'intéresser à la situation
internationale et notamment à la nuit
américaine cette longue attente de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique
contrairement à ce que prédisaient les
sondages et bien c'est très serré entre
donald trump et joba eden on va parler
de tout ça avec deux nouveaux invités
sur ce plateau
mais d'abord le point sur ces élections
avec hugo lemonnier c'était le pire des
scénarios les etats unis se réveille son
président élu est plus divisé que jamais
vers 00h30 joe biden se présente devant
ses partisans depuis son qg de campagne
dans le delaware
cela risque de prendre un peu plus de
temps mais comme je les ai déjà dit tout
au long de la campagne
ce n'est pas à moi ni à donald trump de
déclarer le vainqueur de cette élection
c'est au peuple américain
mais je suis optimiste pour ce résultat
et quelques heures plus tard c'est au
tour de donald trump de prendre la
parole
en tête dans plusieurs états clefs
d'après des résultats partiels le
président des états unis appellent à
cesser le décompte des voix et
revendiquent la victoire
franchement nous avons gagné cette
élection on a gagné c'est une fraude
massive
nous voulons faire respecter le droit
nous allons saisir la cour suprême des
etats unis
nous voulons que le décompte des voix
s'arrête on ne veut pas trouver de
nouveaux bulletins à 4 heures du matin
et les ajouter à la liste
mais dès la fin du discours de donald
trump première manifestation et premiers
heurts dans les villes démocrates comme
ici à seattle un signe inquiétant dans
une élection qui pourrait se jouer
devant les tribunaux ce qui va ce
potentiel mans se passer c'est un
certain nombre de recours auprès de
cours des états voire même de la cour
suprême pour contester le comptage d'un
certain nombre de voix par
correspondance en considérant que ces
voix là ne devrait pas être comptée deux
états seront l'objet de toutes les
attentions dans les prochaines heures
le wiz consignes et le michigan ou trump
hebeisen restent au coude à coude heures
et sur ce plateau cédric perrin bonjour
vous êtes sénateur et l'air du
territoire de belfort vice président de
la commission de la défense et des
affaires étrangères également sur ce
plateau
yannick vaugrenard vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de la loire atlantique est
également membre de la commission de la
défense et des affaires étrangères
cédric perrin votre réaction est bien ce
scrutin où l'incertitude reine qu'est ce
que ça montre sa montre déjà peut-être
qu'une nouvelle fois les sondages se
sont trompés ce qu'ils avaient dit qu'il
y aurait une vague en faveur de joe
biden pour écoutez moi j'ai longuement
comme chacun comme beaucoup j'imagine
suivi des émissions hier soir et suivre
ces élections ce matin je me suis mytho
également devant mon poste de télé ce
que je remarque c'est que finalement
tout le monde se tromper et qu'une fois
de plus peut-être cela donnera-t-il une
leçon à ceux qui voudraient faire
l'élection avant que les électeurs néo
voter parce qu'au final ce qui décide ce
sont ceux qui votent et aux états unis
pour l'instant le résultat n'est pas
connu mais en tout cas tout reste tout
porte à penser quand même que le scrutin
est extrêmement serré en tout cas
beaucoup plus serré qu'une
l'été dans le dans la bouche d'un
certain nombre de son dos et de
journalistes qui depuis quand même
quelques jours maintenant nous explique
qu'un grand renfort de communication que
biden doit gagner etc etc alors je suis
pas du tout un programme que les choses
soient très claires mais je pense dans
cette élection aux états unis comme dans
d'autres sélections dans d'autres pays
qui nous sont très proches et parfois
même très très proches pensent qu'il
faut faire très attention à ce qu'on a
ce qu'on dit et s'est pas loupé c'est
pas la presse qui fait l'opinion mais
c'est l'opinion qui votent oui il ya une
déconnexion entre les élites et le
peuple contre les médias qui ont dans
l'ensemble bien ont passé quatre ans à
la mine et de président américain est
finalement cette opinion publique
américaine qui est resté relativement
stable finalement c'est ce qu'on observe
lors de ce vote et des grenades
oui c'est étonnant parce que c'est le
résultat enfin présumé du scrutin en
tout cas quelques îlots moment où l'on
parle montrent une fracture de la
société américaine que nous n'avons
jamais connu et les états unis sont
quand même l'un des pays les plus
démocratiques en population de sur notre
planète et du coup ce qui est frappant
dans cette élection américaine mais
c'est souvent comme ça lorsqu'une
élection présidentielle aux usa ça
consomme pas seulement les américains ça
concerne le monde entier
reste à dire mais les conséquences
peuvent être lourdes y compris y compris
pour nous deuxième élément et souvenez
de l'évoquer c'est que les instituts son
âge se plantent régulièrement il ce qui
frappe en mai en france aussi a tout le
temps ce qui est frappant c'est que
d'une illusion l'élection suivante nos
billets que donc il faut se fier plutôt
aux programmes et aux personnalités
présentes et à droite ou à gauche ou au
centre
peu importe est plutôt vos instituts de
sondage sont pas les instituts son âge
ni la presse qui fait l'opinion
oui c'est un opéra est ce que c'est donc
une élection cruciale pour la communauté
internationale le monde a été
déstabilisé par la diplomatie de donald
trump qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qui
s'est passé avec eux je suis de ceux qui
considèrent que je pense que l'élection
de joe budden n'aurait pas
fondamentalement changer les choses les
modifications je veux dire devant de
l'état n'aurait ou ne modifierait pas
forcément les choses je sais pas ce qui
se passera
e
mais ce qui est certain c'est que
l'homme la politique internationale des
états unis a changé bien avant
l'élection de donald trump dire déjà
sous obama etc
quand vous prenez une planisphère et que
que vous regardez la plagne notre
planète sous un autre angle celui qu'on
a depuis l'europe mais que vous le
regardez les puits langlois asiatiques
ou pacifique vous vous rendez bien
compte que la halle à ce que ce que les
américains appellent la chaîne de
hollywood à bollywood qui couvre la
moitié de la planète concentre
l'essentiel des enjeux aujourd'hui de
notre bled pour les américains qui se
concentre davantage sur cette partie là
de de l'edm de l'émissaire de
l'hémisphère aujourd'hui ce qui est
important c'est que les européens se
prennent en main et commencent à mettre
en place une politique qui soit une
politique cohérente et surtout unis que
les pays soit uni les uns aux autres
mais dernière chose que je voulais dire
c'est que donald trump depuis qu'il est
élu fait une politique pour les
américains tout le monde s'étonne à
l'international que les résultats soient
cela met de la triplette aujourd'hui
ceux qui voteront pour moi ce sont les
américains ce ne sont pas les chinois
les français les allemands ou je ne sais
qui sont les américains et il a
complètement garder sa base électorale
de 2000 2002 2007 2016 avec près de 40%
qui ne s'est jamais effrité mais ça
montre qu'en tout cas et bien son
élection n'était pas du tout un accident
oui parce que je parte je suis pas tout
à fait ce point de vue pourquoi tout
d'abord nous vivions dans un monde
extrêmement dangereuse que nous n'avons
pas connu probablement depuis 1945 avec
des dirigeants qui sont inquiétants qui
nous préoccupe
sur le plan de la juge estime été
démocratique et sur le plan de leur
rapport au reste de la planète
c'est vrai en russie avec la lumière
poutine c'est vrai avec la fim
c'est vrai avec trump ça l'est aussi
mais un différend avec bonnart ou au
brésil
et ne parlons pas du président turc donc
on voit bien que tous ces dirigeants que
je viens d'évoquer
ce sont des dirigeants qui sont plutôt
populiste populaire populiste c'est à
dire démagogique
et donald trump quand même l'un de ses
premiers messages en quelque sorte
c'était de remettre en cause la
signature de l'amérique
c'étaient les accords de paris sur le
climat ce n'est pas rien oui c était
également capitaine revient il y aurait
peut-être un retour des états unis
bien sûr ça a été la remise on coule de
l'accord national sur le nucléaire
iranien
ça a été la remise en cause d'une forme
de protection sociale qui commençait
avec le ba-ba caire et puis dernièrement
c'est là où je dit donald trump
son seul souci c'est les américains je
suis pas sûr sur le corps on a mis ce
n'est pas le cas quand même un président
des etats-unis qui déclare j'ai pas de
régler les américains sa réélection par
les américains vivant un problème du
coronavirus en injectant du détergent
donc voilà c'est pourquoi je suis pas
indifférent aux résultats des élections
américaines allaient pense que joe biden
le ca se retrouvent chose que donald
trump et on va maintenant rejoindre jean
macé notre streamer politique alors
gentil échange avec ta communauté sur
twitter depuis maintenant environ trois
quarts d'heure alors j'encaisse qui bien
préoccupe aujourd'hui ta communauté en
ce jour de questions d'actu au sénat eh
bien tu aimes tu t'en doutes le gros
sujet c'est celui du rpt confinement
leur confinement fonctionne-t-il oui ou
non les internautes sont eux aussi assez
critique vis-à-vis du gouvernement sur
sa gestion de cette deuxième vague du
coc vide
certains ont posé la question de dire
mais comment est ce qu'on peut imposer
comme ça de manière très autoritaire la
fermeture des petits commerces tout
temps tout en étant empêché visiblement
d'imposer le télétravail le télétravail
reste quelque chose de très plébiscité
par les internautes
certains ont posé la question de savoir
mais est ce qu'on a vraiment des preuves
que dans les petits commerces les fameux
commerce non essentiel et ce qu'on a des
preuves qui a vraiment une circulation
du virus à cet endroit là est-ce que
c'est plus dangereux que de laisser par
exemple les écoles les écoles et lycées
ouverts à propos d'elly c'est d'ailleurs
j'ai beaucoup de lycéens sur le chat qui
est unanime pour dire que les protocoles
sanitaires au lycée sont insuffisants
ils comprennent pour beaucoup les les
manifestations de rue certains haïtiens
qui bloquent leur lycée pour protester
contre la faiblesse des mesures
sanitaires
enfin j'ai posé je suis finalement la
question j'ai fait un petit sondage pour
demander alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de cette ouverture ou pas des
petits commerces fallait-il fermer les
petits commerces faut-il les rouvrir et
bien figure toi que
il ya une vraie division ils sont on est
vraiment limite limite c'est 50 50
il ya un vrai débat actuellement sur sur
le chat sur internet sur ce sujet là le
deuxième sujet qui est très attendu par
les internautes c'est celui de la
sécurité on pense à cette nouvelle loi
sur la sécurité intérieure qui qui qui
arrive le gouvernement qui a l'intention
d'interdire semble-t-il la diffusion des
images de policiers par exemple à
l'occasion des manifestations
et ça les internautes sont assez opposés
à cette idée là l'idée d'empêcher que
l'on puisse continuer à voir par exemple
des exactions ou des violences
policières c'est quelque chose qui il
est qui les énerve beaucoup mais pour
autant la question la suggestion des du
gouvernement qui est de développer
considérablement les caméras piétons
vous savez ces caméras que portent les
policiers sur leur uniforme pour filmer
leurs opérations
ils sont plutôt favorables à cette idée
là en disant mais il les pompiers ont
déjà des caméras certains contrôleurs
dans le métro ou des caméras aussi il
serait temps que les policiers on est à
peu près tous donc voila un petit peu
les sujets qui sont attendus aujourd'hui
table merci merci beaucoup gens pour
toutes ces explications tu viens parler
de reconfirme ans à l'instant c'est un
sujet qui a beaucoup agité également
hier l'assemblée nationale avec le
projet de loi sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui est encore en discussion
là bas et à ce sujet mais on va aller
voir alexandre poussard car alexandre
est avec philippe bas qui est rapporteur
de ce même texte ici au sénat et oui
justement on va réagir sur le désordre
d'hier soir à l'assemblée nationale avec
et bien faute d'une majorité suffisante
de député la république en marche
l'opposition qui a fait passer adopté
ces amendements et imposer au
gouvernement de revenir en décembre pour
prolonger certaines mesures sanitaires
comme le confinement et l'état d'urgence
sanitaire à ce désordre d'hier soir
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire fait débat
d'abord dans une période de crise il
faut que chacun garde son sang froid
il faut que la régulation du travail
gouvernemental et parlementaire se fasse
avec d'autant plus de professionnalisme
que précisément c'est la crise
dans la journée d'hier nous avons connu
trop de rebondissements le matin on nous
annonce que le couvre-feu va s'ajouter
au confinement
puis très peu de temps après on dément
l'information et le soir un mardi soir
alors que tous les députés sont présents
à paris la majorité ne se mobilisent pas
pour faire échec à un amendement tout à
fait légitime qui vise est tout
simplement à faire en sorte que le
parlement se prononce régulièrement sur
les pouvoirs exceptionnels consentis au
gouvernement pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
vous savez que au cours des sept
derniers mois
le parlement s'est prononcé quatre choix
pour autoriser les pouvoirs
exceptionnels du gouvernement et que le
gouvernement dans le texte en cours de
discussion prétend que les pouvoirs
exceptionnels ne donneront pas lieu à un
nouveau vote avant le 1er avril
je comprends les députés qui vont
exactement dans le même sens que le
sénat qui a voté il y a quelques jours
une exigence essentielle c'est que
régulièrement dans notre démocratie
parce que justement on prend des mesures
contre l'épidémie qui limite l'exercice
des libertés individuelles et des
libertés publiques
le parlement doit être plus présent que
jamais parce que c'est la représentation
nationale
la représentation des français dans leur
diversité diversité des territoires
diversité des opinions et que c'est le
lieu de la démocratie et qu'on ne peut
pas restreindre les libertés pour un
motif d'intérêt supérieur la lutte
contre le coc vide 19 sans que le
parlement se prononce régulièrement je
dis tout simplement que si les députés
de la majorité n'étaient pas là hier
soir c'est sans doute qu'ils sont gênés
à l'idée de ne pas défendre les droits
du parlement qui sont en réalité
en démocratie les droits de tous les
citoyens alors dans ce débat sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est ce que le
gouvernement essaye de passer en force a
notamment en réservant le vote sur
certaines mesures à la fin de l'examen
du texte
et puis en estimant que l'opposition
avec ses amendements
voter est irresponsable il me semble que
le gouvernement pourrait se donner le
temps de la réflexion cette fois au lieu
d'agir à l'impulsion pourquoi je dis ça
il me semble que le parlement qui a voté
quatre fois les pouvoirs exceptionnels
de lutte contre la crise n'est pas
soupçonnable de ne pas avoir l'esprit de
responsabilité mais cet esprit de
responsabilité doit être assortie d'une
exigence de vigilance et c'est la seule
chose que nous demandons au gouvernement
une chose qu'il a accepté pendant les
sept premiers mois de la crise et que
soudain il refuse pour avoir les mains
totalement libres sans avoir de comptes
à rendre
et bien c'est pas comme ça que doit
fonctionner une démocratie mais surtout
si vous voulez quand vous êtes au
gouvernement faire accepter des mesures
difficiles il faut les faire partager
l'acceptabilité des contraintes imposées
aux français dépend du fait que le
parlement aura à se prononcer
régulièrement parce que ça c'est une
garantie pour les français merci
beaucoup fait débat les questions merci
beaucoup alexandre une réaction yannick
vaugrenard à ce que vient de dire
philippe bas c'est un sujet d'accord
pour le coup pour les oppositions de
dire il faut que eh bien on puisse avoir
des clauses de revoyure sur l'état
d'urgence qu'il soit plus haut puis plus
restreinte dans le temps que ce qui a
été prévu par le gospel points si bien
sûr je crois que c'est le fonctionnement
même de notre démocratie et c'est prévu
dans la constitution
je regrette que le gouvernement me
donnent le sentiment de se cabrer un peu
c'est vrai que la situation que nous
traversons est particulièrement
difficile tous les pays la traverse
mais il faut faire preuve de bon sens et
de sagesse et pour être efficace il faut
associer tout le monde et l'accès y
compris l'option d'irresponsabilité dans
ce combat parce que ça vient d'être
appelé à maintes reprises nous avons
prorogé l'état d'urgence en toute
responsabilité
mais on peut pas faire tout et n'importe
quoi et par ailleurs pour notre devoir
en tant que parlementaires c'est de
faire des propositions c'était le cas
sur le petit commerce également où la
précipitation est souvent mauvaise
conseillère moi je vous dis il faudrait
peut-être que dans la période que nous
traversons gouvernement et puisse nommer
un ministre du bon sens et de la sagesse
et rue
c'est récupère un très beau moment là
dessus je partage entièrement ce qui a
été dit par philippe bas je crois qu'il
a extrêmement bien résumé les choses le
parlement est aussi là pour contrôler
l'action du gouvernement il est
parfaitement légitime qu'on puisse le
faire
je pense que le gouvernement souffre de
deux symptômes particuliers est d'abord
un certain amateurisme je rappelle quand
même que nous avons vécu un 1er
confinement qui nous a permis de tirer
un certain nombre de leçons dont on n'a
pas vraisemblablement fin donc certains
n'ont pas vraiment pris la mesure
puisque aujourd'hui on se retrouve à la
deuxième confinement et les problèmes
sont les mêmes voire sont amplifiées
puis le deuxième c'est que
malheureusement il ya aucun ministre
pour incarner une autorité aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de mise de poids pour
pouvoir incarner quelque chose de 2,2
d'important et on se rend bien compte
qu'à l'assemblée nationale comme au
sénat tout à l'heure il ya une vraie
lacune il ya de vrais un vrai problème
de casting on va enchaîner sur les
autres sujets qui vont être abordés lors
de cette séance de questions et tout de
suite on va rejoindre alexandre poussard
vous êtes avec esther benbassa sénatrice
écologiste de paris
et oui on va parler durant cette séance
de questions d'actualité des attentats
terroristes qui ont frappé un autre sol
également le sol autrichien avec un
débat sur l'immigration puisque les
auteurs de ces attentats étaient
étrangers alors esther benbassa bonjour
alors vous êtes une des spécialistes
hisser au sénat de l'immigration de la
radicalisation
est-ce qu'il faut revoir notre état de
droit en matière d'immigration pour
lutter plus efficacement contre le
terrorisme
peut-être qu'il faudrait d'abord
commencer par combattre autrement le
terrorisme c'est très important avec
madame
catherine tremblay nous avions fait un
rapport il ya quelques années elle est l
air et moi je suis écologiste est sûre
la déradicalisation je crois que une
fois que le lac terroriste est passé et
on oublie ce qui s'est passé on n'oublie
pas mais on occulte quelque part parce
que qu'est ce que nous avons fait et
pour changer à part des lois qu'est ce
que nous avons fait pour changer les
choses
regardez pharos il n'y a pas assez de
personnes pour suivre ce qui se passe
sur les réseaux
nous n'avons plus d'aidé renseignements
généraux depuis sarkozy
maintenant c'est les renseignements ça a
été des structures et il n'ya on a
remplacé par des algorithmes les êtres
humains nous ne faisons pas grand chose
dans l'est et dans les prisons pour
endiguer le terrorisme nous ne faisons
pas de plan banlieues pour faire revenir
l'état qui est absent
désormais de ces quartiers les services
publics sont absents la police de
proximité est absente
vous croyez pas ce qu'on va empêcher
quelques personnes de venir en france
qu'on va régler la question du
terrorisme
il me semble que je chemin est encore
long il faudrait réfléchir à toutes ces
questions
elle ne pas occulter les vrais problèmes
avant de s'attaquer à l'immigration qui
est un sujet du hellen un sujet facile
et racoleur et ne pas oublier les
questions sociales mais aussi bien sur
les questions sociales c'est que vous
avez le terrorisme
hélas ne fleurit que sur la pauvreté la
précarité alors tout le monde le sait et
ce n'est pas nouveau
merci beaucoup esther benbassa pour
votre intervention merci beaucoup
alexandre votre réaction
cédric perrin alors que est bien la
question du terrorisme islamiste a
frappé bien sûr à plusieurs reprises la
france ces derniers temps mais aussi
l'autriche lundi avec une attaque au
coeur de la capitale ça montre aussi
bien que c'est l'ensemble de l'europe de
l'ouest qui est aujourd'hui fortement
concernés par la menace djihadiste
mon côté oui cette terrible attaque qui
est survenu à vienne prouve une fois de
plus que le problème n'est pas celui des
caricatures qui a été mis qui étaient
dressés pour pour essayer de justifier
certains actes injustifiables
le problème il est que l'islam radical
l'islam politique veut prendre le
pouvoir chez nous que les choses soient
très claires aujourd'hui 7 en france et
en autriche et et dans les jours
malheureusement on sait très bien que ça
peut frapper n'importe quel pays à
n'importe quel moment et tout à l'heure
nous parlions de la nécessité de
l'europe de se prendre en main vis-à-vis
des etats-unis qui nous abandonne
quelque peu depuis quelques temps je
pense que sur cette problématique de
lutte contre le terrorisme il faut aussi
que les pays européens leur globalité
commencent à prendre conscience que le
terrorisme peut frapper celle à chacun
d'entre nous et que nous puissions être
uni contre ce terrorisme
quand on voit que la france est la seule
aujourd'hui avec quelques aides partiel
est la seule aujourd'hui aller se battre
au mali par exemple dans l'opération
barkan pour essayer de lutter contre le
terrorisme ce n'est plus acceptable
il faut que nous soyons aider il nous
faut des alliés et il faut que dans
cette opération nous considérions tout
ce que nous sommes en guerre nimbuzz est
d'accord là dessus il faut une politique
européen
c'est une évidence je vais pas faire
preuve de naïveté
nous sommes dans une situation où
l'islamisme politique l'islamisme
radical ne supporte pas la manière dont
nous vivons la manière dont nous sommes
libres la manière dont nous pensons de
magnin nous écrivons dont nous dessinons
et donc c'est en quelque sorte un peu un
choc de civilisation auquel nous avons
affaire à faire face et que nous
constatons face à cela il me semble
qu'il fouille d'une forme d'unité
politique qui m'apparaît indispensable
et d'unité européenne également car
n'arrivera pas le faire tout seul sur
notre territoire en france nous pour le
faire avec l'autriche avec les allemands
avec les britanniques même s'il ya le
bric site je pense que c'est l'unité
européenne qui nous permettra d beaucoup
plus efficace par rapport à cet
islamisme radical
voilà un sujet qui met d'accord lr et
socialistes merci beaucoup à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à ce face à face
et tout ce qu'on va rejoindre alexandre
plus à vous êtes avec pierre jean
verzeaux laine qui va poser une question
tout à leurs sénateurs disent
indépendants de l'aisne et a posé une
question sur les petits connards je
crois oui la fermeture des commerces non
essentiel et des petits commerces de
proximité pendant leur confinement c'est
un sujet qui va marquer cette séance de
questions d'actualité
et beaucoup d'élus locaux également à
des sénateurs sont vent debout contre
cette mesure mais une pierre jean
verzeaux l'aisne il ya quand même une
nécessité sanitaire
commençons par affirmer que dans la
période actuelle la priorité des
priorités c'est la santé publique
et c'est la santé des français le
gouvernement s'est enfermé
si vous me le permettez sur la notion de
produits de première nécessité et quand
vous mettez
le doigt dans ce sujet là vous vous en
sortez plus parce que chaque jour
apportera son lot de produits de
première nécessité on n'est pas loin des
fêtes de noël et pour beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de choses qui vont devenir des
produits de première nécessité pour les
français pour l'organisation de la vie
donc ce qu'il vous êtes loaded ce qui
doit être la boussole pour l'ouverture
l'ouverture partielle ou la distribution
d'aidé commerce ce qui doit être la
boussole c'est le respect des consignes
sanitaires
donc pour vous il faut pouvoir ouvrir
tous les commerces qui tu as peut-être
augmenter le risque sanitaire
c'est parce que je en train de vous dire
je vous dis que la boussole ce doit être
le respect des préconisations sanitaire
et la sécurité des français
là où c'est possible on our là où c'est
pas possible on n'ouvre pas le groupe
par des ouvertures partielles ont fait
du partiel
là où fut un autre mode district de
distribution pardon on fait un autre
mode de distribution
mais pour ceux artisans indépendants
commerçants qui auront des pertes de
chiffres d'affaires
là on doit être au rendez vous on doit
être capable de leur donner de la
visibilité et de compenser les pertes
qui durera est ce que vous estimez que
le gouvernement est au rendez vous pour
soutenir ces petits commerçants qui sont
au bord de la faillite
dans les propos pour l'instant oui j'ai
pas encore compris précisément comment
tout ça allait fonctionner donc c'est la
question que je poserai toutes à leur
merci beaucoup et on va écouter
attentivement votre question durant
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement on va retrouver la tribune
de presse de l'hémicycle avec steve qui
va nous présenter le programme de cette
séance
oui alex y sera évidemment question vous
l'avez ni de la crise sanitaire et de la
mise en oeuvre de ce second confinement
peut-être quelques éléments de contexte
le pour mettre un peu ces questions
d'actualité en perspective le texte sur
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
il est toujours en débat au parlement
l'assemblée nationale on l'a vu tout à
l'heure a voté hier deux amendements qui
ont fait beaucoup de bruit deux
amendements qui remettent en cause un la
date voulue par le gouvernement pour la
fin de l'état d'urgence mais aussi pour
la fin du confinement en gros les
députés ont exigé du gouvernement qu'il
repasse le gouvernement devant le
parlement au plus vite il en sera
peut-être question dans quelques
instants la séance vient de débuter on
en reparle juste après sur public sénat
[Musique]
je n'en vois point de procès verbal est
adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues de religion rappelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
la séance est retransmise en direct sur
public sénat sur notre site internet au
nom du sénat de son bureau
j'appelle chacun d'un vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges d'une valeur essentielle du
sénat le respect des uns des autres au
respect du temps de parole et de
respecter l'ensemble des gestes
barrières sur lequel nous avons adressé
avec les questeurs à courrier il y a
quelques jours
la parole est à madame laurence harribey
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
j'avais la parole merci monsieur le
président oui la situation sanitaire est
grave
oui des dispositions contraignantes
devait être prise comme dans tous les
pays européens
oui il faut freiner la circulation du
virus pour permettre aux soignants de
tenir
oui nous devons faire preuve de
responsabilité et nous l'avons fait en
votant la déclaration du gouvernement
mais faut-il encore que les décisions
soient logique et équitable
comment justifier la fermeture des
petits commerces qui appliquent les
protocoles sanitaires au prétexte qu'il
ne serait pas essentiel
comment justifier qu'acheter un fer à
repasser dans une grande enseigne soit
plus essentiel qu acheter un livre en
librairie
comment justifier que monter dans un bus
pour aller travailler soit plus sûr
qu'une balade en forêt à plus d'un
kilomètre de chez soi la question est
simple
où est la logique pour quelle efficacité
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état chargé de la
transition numérique
monsieur cédric ur
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice harribey et je voudrais
commencer et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs par excusé et bruno le maire
et alain griset qui sont actuellement en
réunion avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales ainsi que les
fédérations de commerçants pour discuter
de la période compliquée que vous avez
évoquées vous évoquez madame la
sénatrice la situation sanitaire et vous
juste titre chercher à déceler la
logique des prises de décisions du
gouvernement revenir peut-être sur la
situation sanitaire tel que vous l'avez
décrites
je rappelle que ce que nous devions
faire dans le cadre où le fameux air
c'est à dire le taux de reproduction du
virus était à 1,6 c'était le passé à 0.8
donc diviser par deux les interactions
sociales des français divisé par deux
les interactions sociales des français
c'est pourquoi nous avons dû prendre des
décisions extrêmement difficile de
réduction de ces interactions sociales à
travers le confinement nous avons pris
une décision difficile aussi de
conserver les écoles ouvertes et de
conserver le travail dès lors qu'il ne
pouvait y avoir lieu d'une fois y avoir
de télétravail car les la solution a été
pire que le mal mais si nous avions
accès dès la demande que vous faites
aujourd'hui madame la sénatrice
si nous avions donc laisser l'ensemble
des commerces ouverts mais alors le
confinement serait revenu exactement à
fermer les bars et les restaurants
et c'est donc avec une grande difficulté
mais avec une grande responsabilité
également que nous avons pris cette
décision qui est de limiter les
déplacements des français ils se
déplacent ils voient d'autres personnes
il côtoie d'autres personnes dans ce
qu'il vend dans les commerces
et si vous appelez à réouvrir l'ensemble
des commerces alors cela veut dire
mécaniquement que le confinement
équivaut à fermer uniquement les bars et
les récents
madame arriver
vous avez l'art de déformer les propos
et le fait que ce soit vous qui
répondiez est très significatif du
respect du parlement
l'un porte l'important ce n'est pas de
comprendre les frustrations des uns des
autres c'est que la décision soit
accepté et pour qu'elles soient
acceptables il faut qu'elle soit
compréhensive et 6,7 acceptabilité
passer par un changement de méthode
quelques propositions changer la logique
en privilégiant les protocoles
sanitaires plutôt qu'en raisonnant par
produits essentiels ou par type de
commerce
faire contribuer ceux qui tirent parti
de la crise comme les gaffes en faveur
d'un fonds de soutien au commerce de
proximité
parce que les parce que les innovations
viennent des territoires fait confiance
aux élus territoriaux et enfin parce
qu'il est impossible d'aller d'état
d'urgence en état d'urgence sans
concertation modifions la gouvernance de
cette crise en s'appuyant sur le père le
parlement plutôt qu'en lui donnant la
leçon commis hier soir à l'assemblée
nationale
aucune us est décompté pour que la
responsabilité soit partagée encore
faut-il que la décision soit aussi
partager la parole et à christian bilhac
quand le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
je me serais économie la deuxième vague
de l'épidémie de covin frappe notre pays
de plein fouet le nombre de personnes
infectées dépasse les chiffres du mois
de mars et d'indicateurs sont au rouge
face à la gravité de la situation le
gouvernement a décidé par décret le 29
octobre et selon des critères bien fou
de fermer les commerces dits non
essentiels parmi lesquels nombre de
petits commerces de proximité
cette décision soulève une
incompréhension doublée d'un sentiment
d'injustice pour les professionnels qui
avaient mis en place des mesures pour
garantir la sécurité sanitaire de leurs
salariés de leurs clients des flacons de
gel hydroalcoolique le port du masque
obligatoire
le nombre de clients a limité les locaux
je redoute que cette fermeture sur le
coup de grâce pour l'économie locale
alors que les mastodontes du commerce en
ligne de la grande distribution restent
ouverts cette différence de traitement
introduit une discrimination
alors que faire ses courses dans un
hypermarché comporte plus de risques de
promiscuité qu'à jeter un livre dans une
librairie qui limitait la présence des
clients en boutique
autre exemple que dans la commune de
père et demie l'habitat j'étais maire
longtemps il y à un salon de coiffure
il serait possible d'accueillir un
client à la fois en appliquant des
règles sanitaires strictes sans pourtant
contribué à la propagation du virus
ailleurs des maires ont pris en toute
illégalité des arrêtés pour ses
commerces et l'association des maires de
france demandait un communiqué le
réexamen de la notion de commerce de
première nécessité pour répondre à la
grogne vous avez annoncé dimanche un
fonds de 100 millions d'euros des deux
pour accélérer la digitalisation et
mettre en place le service du clic
incorrect en compagne et d'incitations
financières
enfin le long de nos chances de survivre
à ce nouveau confinement et pastis
assurances indispensables à vie sociale
économique nos communes
le groupe rodez et moi même nous
demandons monsieur le ministre
d'autoriser des petits commerces de
proximité
par dérogation accordée par le préfet à
la demande des maires
la mise en place de ce système
dérogatoire remettra au coeur du
dispositif le couple maire au préfet on
vous répond de la parole et au
secrétaire d'état cdh rico
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je tiens à rappeler
pour commencer à la chambre et autres
que la constitution dont nous nous
réclamons nous réclamons tous stipule
que n'importe quel ministre du
gouvernement est habilité à représenter
l'ensemble dû gouvernement et à répondre
à sa place et que donc dans la condition
dans les situations qu'elles qu'elles
sont c'est à dire la nécessité de
continuer à concerter comme vous nous
appelez à le faire et comme bruno le
maire et alain gretz sont appelés à le
faire en ce moment il se trouve que
c'est moi qui vous répond cela me permet
de revenir
monsieur le sénateur sur tout de même
l'engagement exceptionnel qui a été
celui de ce gouvernement pour soutenir
les petits commerces dans la situation
compliquée qui est la leur je pense tout
d'abord à l'extension du fonds de
solidarité qui revient mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à ce que un
commerce aujourd'hui qui fait moins de
10000 euros de chiffre d'affaires ce qui
est probablement la majorité des petits
commerces qui en novembre 2019 faisait
six ou sept mille euros de chiffre
d'affaires se verra intégralement
compensé son chiffre d'affaires jusqu'à
10000 euros
mieux le fait même que le click and
collect ne soient pas intégrés au
chiffre d'affaires fait qu'un commerce
qui aurait fait moins de 10000 euros
chiffre d'affaires en novembre 2019
pourrait en novembre 2020 faire un
chiffre d'affaires meilleur que son
chiffre d'affaires en 2010 9,7 en gamme
mais vérifiez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est la réalité vécue de vos
petits commerces
ce qui conduit d'ailleurs une partie des
côtes e-commerce a préféré la fermeture
à la réouverture avec des protocoles
sanitaires beaucoup trop contraignant
parce qu'à un quoi parce qu'un client
par salon de coiffure la réalité
économique fait qu'il n'y a pas
d'intérêt à rouvrir
et donc c'est un engagement très fort
sur le fond de solidarité 15 milliards
d'euros par mois c'est un mec un
engagement sur les cotisations sociales
c'est un engagement sur le prêt est
garanti par étape qui a été prolongée
jusqu'au 30 juin 2021
dans ces conditions la situation est
compliquée mais l'état est aux côtés des
petits commerces
la parole est à notre collègue daniel
salmon pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
confinement est devenu indispensable
pour la sécurité sanitaire
mais les petits commerçants payent un
lourd tribut ils sont obligés une
seconde fois de fermer boutique et
vivent une situation dramatique
de plus les mesures mises en place à
traduisent une inégalité de traitement
avec les grandes et moyennes surfaces
d'une part et les géants du numérique
d'autre part une inégalité insoutenable
comment accepter cette situation
invraisemblable nos petits commerces
obligé de fermer et en parallèle des
entrepôts d'amazon qui s'implantent un
peu partout dans notre territoire
ce modèle économique n'est pas durable
il est à l'origine de dizaines de
milliers de destructions d'emploi dans
les commerces traditionnels
c'est un modèle qui participent à la
dévitalisation de nos centres villes
un modèle qui bétonnent nos terres
agricoles un modèle qui a un bilan
carbone catastrophique
j'en appelle également à la
responsabilité de toutes et tous ici et
notamment aux collègues de droite de
cette émission demandé la
requalification de nos productions et
appelé à plus de nous souveraineté c'est
bien mais il ne faut pas pleurer la mort
des petits commerces de proximité et en
parallèle autorisé des implantations et
des extensions de grandes surfaces ainsi
qu'à accepter la construction de 20
nouveaux entrepôts géants d'amazones un
peu partout en france
car c'est bien de la responsabilité des
élus locaux d'accepter ou non
l'implantation de ces sites sur leur
commune comme abel un baylet en gironde
où le géant chinois alibaba va implanter
71 1000 m² d'entrepôts logistiques en
plein parc naturel régional mais aussi à
ensisheim dans le haut rhin ou encore à
montbert en loire atlantique et la liste
est longue
je pourrais également parlé des
conditions sanitaires des salariés dans
la vente en ligne
monsieur le ministre pour enfin trouver
le chemin d'un modèle économique juste
et résilients soyons efficaces sans
attendre
à quand un gel des implantations
d'entrepôts de vente en ligne comme le
demande la convention citoyenne et un
moratoire sur leur ouverture
à quand une contribution exceptionnelle
d'amazon et des grandes surfaces en
faveur des commerçants et artisans
obligé de fermer
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur seulement
je vous remercie pour votre question
parce que elle me permet de remettre en
perspective la réalité de ce que
représente amazon dans notre pays oui
évidemment il s'agit d'accompagner les
petits commerces
nous avons eu l'occasion d'en parler je
pense que dans la suite des questions
nous allons continuer à en parler mais
je veux rappeler les chiffres de
l'e-commerce
il y actuellement une psychose française
sur amazon qui n'a pas beaucoup de sens
le e-commerce c'est 10% du commerce en
france amazon c'est 20% du e-commerce en
france y'a pas un pays européen où
amazon et plus bas qu'en france quand
les français augmentent leurs achats de
e-commerce à 60%
ça vient dans les poches des commerçants
français d'entrepreneurs français de
salariés français d'entrepôts français
comme cdiscount chez la sénatrice
harribey ces deux mille emplois et grâce
au confinement grâce au click and
collect c'est plus d'emplois en france
plus d'entrepôt en français plus de
salariés en france et donc la psychose
française sur amazon n'a absolument
aucun sens
aucun sens amazon devrait-il doubler sa
part de marché soit à 4% et donc le fond
du sujet sur lequel nous devons
travailler et avec lequel nous
travaillons avec les collectivités
territoriales je rappelle que la banque
des territoires finances pour chaque
mairie vingt mille euros pour faire des
places de marché local c'est de
numériser les petits commerces
il y à 30% des petits commerces qui sont
numérisés en france 72 % en allemagne
c'est ça le fond du problème
si nous ne sommes pas capables de les
amener à ceux numérisés plus si nous ne
sommes pas capables de doubler le nombre
de tpe pme qui sont numérisés comme en
italie alors inexorablement lee commerce
français d'abord je rappelle que 60% du
commerce est captée par des entreprises
françaises comme la fnac com cdiscount
com mano mano comme comme miracle' si
nous ne sommes pas capables de le faire
alors dans la durée
les petits commerces que les troncs des
difficultés
la parole est à notre collègue pierre
jean verzeaux laine pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
il avait la parole monsieur monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues il n'ya pas d'élus
responsables des élus qui sont
responsables et des élus qui ne sont pas
responsables
dans cet hémicycle nous savons que de
gouverner dans cette période actuelle
est quelque chose qui n'est pas évident
et réaffirmant que la santé la santé
publique la santé des français c'est la
priorité qui est au dessus de celle de
toutes les autres dans la période que
nous sommes en train de vivre
le président de la république la semaine
dernière a annoncé leur confinement
reconfirme ans que nous pouvons
qualifier de partiels les écoles les
collèges les lycées sont ouverts
certains commerces des grandes surfaces
des gaffes à des grands groupes tiff qui
livre les foyers fonctionne et d'autres
sont fermés et on constate que dans le
pays
sacré de nombreuses incompréhensions qui
sont légitimes
je vais vous dire enfin je vais y aller
de mon conseil sortez de cette notion de
produits de première nécessité si vous
mettez le doigt là dedans
vous n'en sortirais jamais tous les
jours vous aurez nouveaux produits de
première nécessité qui auront des
arguments qui tiennent la route
la boussole ce doit être la sécurité
sanitaire
on peut rouvrir si la sécurité sanitaire
et respecté on peut pas si c'est pas
possible réouverture partielle si c'est
comme ça et il ya des commerces dont
qu'il irait ouvriront d'autres qui
auront des fonctionnements
à la marge d'autres qui seront livraison
mais là où on a un devoir ou vous avez
un devoir c'est d'être d'être au
rendez-vous d'apporter à ces commerçants
assez indépendant de la visibilité
un soutien et une confiance et un
accompagnement qu'il mérite et que tout
est que le nous leur devons merci de
votre attention pour vous répondre la
parole et à monsieur le premier ministre
[Musique]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur j'ai souhaité j'ai
souhaité à ce stade intervenir dans
cette séance
pour bien repris 6 et bien que je les
fais ici même monsieur le président
jeudi dernier quelle est la stratégie du
gouvernement en vous demandant mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs que nous nous
écoutions au moins la gravité de la
situation le mérite t'elle hier soir
hier soir hier soir je me suis rendu
avec le ministre de la santé à l'hôpital
du sud francilien que beaucoup d'entre
vous connaissent ici je vous assure que
ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai entendu des
soignants témoigne d'une gravité de la
situation sanitaire dans la prise en
compte est le préalable de toutes les
décisions et de tous les débats que ces
décisions suscite légitimement hier
encore plus de 430 personnes sont mortes
en france
cette maladie touche toutes les tranches
d'âge
même en réanimation hier à corbeil
essonnes dans un état très grave il y
avait des deux patients l'un de 27 ans
l'un de 33 ans
personne n'est à l'abri comme dans tous
les pays
je les ai expliqué et réexpliqué on doit
y naviguer à vue aussi puisque là-bas
aussi le déconfinement a conduit à des
mesures de freinage très lourde voire à
deir confinement la vérité au delà des
polémiques politiciennes
la vérité c'est que cette épidémie cette
deuxième vague est là qu'elle est
arrivée
beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup plus fort
que tout le monde l'avait pensé et que
nous avons été conduits à amplifier les
mesures que nous avons prises ces
mesures vous la connaissez ça a été dit
par plus d'entre vous cette un nouveau
record finement leur confinement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est quoi vous le savez c'est faire en
sorte qu on reste chez soi le
déconfinement on est libre de sortir et
tous les lieux où l'on va sont entourés
de protocole sanitaire
la logique du confinement c'est de
laisser le maximum de gens chez eux
d'éviter les flux d'éviter les
interactions qui sont propices à la
propagation équipe épidémie vous avez
parlé à juste titre de d1 confinement
adapté oui nous vous avons écouté le oui
nous avons tiré les conséquences du
premier du premier confinement écoutez
moi au premier confinement je vous le
rappelle on pouvait déjà allé travailler
déjà prendre les transports en commun
pour aller travailler
y a rien de nouveau au premier
confinement au premier confinement en
revanche nous avions fermé tous les
établissements scolaires et nous en
avons tiré les conclusions parce que
cette décision emporte et vous me l'avez
souvent dit des conséquences extrêmement
préjudiciables notamment pour nos
enfants et des études scientifiques
à commencer par la très sérieuse société
française de pédiatrie nous en dit
surtout ne recopie n'est pas les enfants
c'est ce que nous avons fait donc ça
veut dire effectivement que nous avons
moins reconfirmer que la première étape
est donc et donc on ne peut pas aller au
delà la troisième exception confinement
c'était de sortir c'est soit pour
acheter des produits de première
nécessité pour manger c'est ce qu'on a
maintenu et on l'a maintenu davantage
parce qu'on nous a dit c'est un débat
qui avait peu émergé à la première phase
à la première phase on avait laissé les
grandes surfaces ouvertes tout rayon
c'était déjà il égalitaire c'était déjà
inégalitaire bon et ça l'est toujours
on en a tiré des conséquences et ce sont
des conséquences adapté mesdames et
messieurs sather parce que ses
conséquences sont cohérentes avec la
décision de sécurité sanitaire puisque
en fermant des rayons dans les grandes
surfaces
nous allons limiter les flux et les
occasions de sorties parce que je le
répète le confinement
c'est de rester chez soi le plus
possible et vous le savez alors pour le
coup pour le coup doit-on accompagner
tous ces secteurs que nous fermons et
qui n'y peuvent rien
c'est un crève coeur ils ne demandent
qu'à bosser et ils ont raison
donc on doit les indemniser et là aussi
d'ailleurs vous l'avez reconnu y at il
un pays en europe qui accompagne au
mieux son économie qui soutiennent yeux
les secteurs que nous fermons pas
nécessité sanitaire
y en at il un seul y en at il un seul je
vous le demande
ce matin le conseil des ministres a
adopté le projet de loi de finances
rectificative numéro 4 qui comprendra
toutes les mesures de soutien que
monsieur a décrites
j'espère que vous le vôtre et j'espère
que vous le vôtre et et tous ses
commerces
on les reçoit on les accompagne on
prépare l'échéance du 12 novembre
mais on ne pourra la tenir que si la
situation sanitaire s'améliore donc je
n'ai pas vous le savez une décision
contre eux c'est une décision pour la
santé des français je vous remercie
merci monsieur j'ai vu
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
dominique estrosi sassone pour le groupe
b réduit
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
dit à mes enfants que je les aime ce
sont les derniers mots prononcés par
simone lâchement assassinés comme nadine
et vincent en plein coeur de la
basilique notre-dame de nice par ce
terroriste immigrés tunisiens islamiste
radicale la france veut aujourd'hui
déclaré la guerre à l'islamisme
politique qui veut détruire nos valeurs
nos libertés notre civilisation mais la
france se donne t elle vraiment les
moyens de livrer cette guerre
l'immigration n'est pas la cause
première du terrorisme mais les trois
derniers adaptant attentat que nous
venons de vivre nous confirme qu'elle
est une des conditions il est temps de
stopper le désordre migratoires
chaque année 300 mille personnes
essentiellement issus des pays musulmans
entrent légalement en france auxquels il
faut ajouter 150 mille demandeurs
d'asile alors monsieur le premier
ministre je vous demande solennellement
êtes vous prêt à revoir les critères
d'obtention du droit d'asile souvent
aujourd'hui détourné
êtes vous prêt à réduire au maximum le
regroupement familial que votre
gouvernement a souhaité étendre aux
mineurs étrangers isolés
elle vous prêt à remettre à plat
totalement le droit des étrangers pour
que nous donnions vraiment les moyens
d'expulser
la parole éclat monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice je choisis la encore de vous
répondre
compte tenu de la gravité la gravité du
du sujet de votre terre d'élection
chère madame la sénatrice où je me
rendrai vous le savez ça me dit et je
commence évidemment avec vous tous comme
vous l'avez fait par avoir une pensée
pour les victimes odieusement lâchement
assassinés à nice ces trois victimes
ces trois victimes qui hélas vous l'avez
dit font suite à d'autres trop
nombreuses trop nombreuses vous
m'interrogez légitimement sur la
politique que le gouvernement conduit
face à cet ennemi
pardonnez-moi de rectifier qui nous a
déclaré la guerre qui nous a déclaré la
guerre et je les dis et je le répète
devant vous cet ennemi qu'il faut
clairement identifiés
c'est la première condition pour gagner
une guerre et nous la gagnerons cet
ennemi
il a un nom je les dis ce n'est pas tout
les étrangers vous l'avez d'ailleurs
vous même reconnu dans votre question
ce ne sont pas tous les musulmans ce
sont les tenants de l'islamisme radical
qui ont des connexions à l'étranger et
qui vous le savez hélas on des relais en
france y compris des citoyens de
nationalité française
ces personnes quelles qu'elles soient
nous devons les traquer j'entends les
questions depuis de nombreuses années
d'ailleurs pour cela il faut modifier la
loi voire davantage
je ne ferai pas l'injure au sénat ou au
parlement général de dénombrer le nombre
de textes législatifs toute majorité
confondues
qui sont intervenus en la matière notre
rôle notre rôle madame la sénatrice
c'est de veiller à l'effectivité et à
l'application des lois existantes et je
peux vous dire et je peux vous dire que
c'est ce que nous faisons bien sûr
madame le corpus législatif mérite
sûrement d'être adapté je pense
notamment nous en avons déjà parlé dans
cet hémicycle au support des réseaux
sociaux dont se servent les ennemis de
la république pour frapper la république
là vous avez tout à fait raison il faut
revoir la réglementation mais il faudra
là encore surtout l'appliquer renforcer
les moyens de suivi des réseaux sociaux
renforcer les moyens de renseignement ce
que nous avons très largement fait est
que nous allons continuer à faire et
d'ailleurs vous le savez bien avant bien
avant
l'odieux attentat de conflans sainte
honorine le président de la république
avait annoncé un projet de loi qui vous
le verrez sera très ambitieux pour
renforcer nos outils de lutte contre cet
ennemi mais les actes de ce secteur
regardez encore aujourd'hui nous avons
dissous une association nous en faisons
tous les mercredis nous allons les
débusquer parce que ce sont des lâches
ils se servent de fausses associations
vous le savez ils s'introduisent dans
des mosquées ou des imams radicaux
brèche non pas la religion mais la n 1
par 1 nous les traquerons madame
estrosi sassone monsieur le premier
ministre je regrette que vous n'ayez
absolument pas répondu aux trois
questions que je vous ai posé qui
concernait les flux migratoires massifs
aujourd'hui l'immigration massive elle
fragilise notre pays
et si nous voulons tous ensemble relever
le défis communs de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et nous sommes tous unis pour
cela parce que nous voulons nous voulons
tous défendre la france je suis désolé
monsieur le premier ministre il faut
aussi réguler les flux migratoires
massifs
parce que c'est aussi comme ça que nous
arriverons à relever le défi de
l'intégration est à refaire communauté
merci la parole est à notre collègue
françoise férat pour le groupe de
l'union centriste avait la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
et encore une encore une question liée à
la fermeture des petits commerces mais
vous l'avez remarqué site une inquiétude
sur tous les bancs de c'était de cet
hémicycle les mesures sanitaires sont
primordiales n'y revenons pas mais la
fermeture des petits commerces et
difficilement compréhensible
cette décision va susciter un drame
économique car ils sont à bout de
souffle
malgré les aides nombre d'entre eux ni
survivre pas leur interdire d'ouvrir
s'est encore creusé la dette et elle
vous redire l'addition du chômage
partiel
cette fermeture est aussi un drame
humain ce sont eux qui surtout en zone
rurale tisse le lien social et surtout
lorsque l'on sait que 13 millions de
français ne sont pas connectés click and
collect n'est en aucun cas un substitut
monsieur le ministre je vous monsieur le
premier ministre je vous ai bien entendu
mais aucune étude n'a encore démontré
que librairie coiffeur auto écoles
étaient des clusters d'autant moins que
les commerçants ont investi pour
s'adapter à la situation
pour que la distanciation sociale et les
gestes barrières et soit toujours
respecté aujourd'hui nous avons un débat
absurde sur les produits essentiels et
non essentiels la patate la pâte à
tartiner est essentielle mais pas les
livres à côté de cela les sites internet
sont ouverts 24 heures sur 24 pour
vendre les produits non essentiels donc
pour enrichir les gaffes a déjà
milliardaires et non contributeurs
décembre ou rire ceux qui font la vie
des centres bourgs et des centres villes
lors de l'examen du pgl prorogeant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire le sénat a
fait adopter à l'unanimité l'unanimité
un amendement pour que le préfet puisse
autoriser l'ouverture des commerces de
vente au détail
ne peut-on pas être un peu plus créatifs
qu'une interdiction uniforme
ne peut-on pas autoriser les ouvertures
des petits commerces en fonction des
situations locales
ne peut-on pas autoriser les ouvertures
selon des mesures plus fines prise de
rendez-vous un ou deux clients par
boutique
n'est ce pas cela répondre à l'urgence
sanitaire tout en ménageant l'urgence
économique
et si vous faisiez un peu confiance aux
territoires pour vous répondre
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
chargé de la production numérique
monsieur rigaux
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice et ayant eu l'occasion de
répondre tout à l'heure je vais me
permettre de me concentrer sur les
mesures d aide parce qu'il me semble
qu'elles sont encore insuffisamment
connus jusqu aux petits commerçants et
qu'il est indispensable notamment grâce
à votre appui mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que nous puissions faire
savoir ce qui est à disposition des
petits conversant tout d'abord sur le
fond de solidarité
toutes les entreprises fermées
administrativement de moins de 50
salariés bénéficieront d'une aide
mensuelle mensuels allant jusqu'à dix
mille euros sans exception les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés des
secteurs du tourisme de l'hôtellerie
restauration de l'événementiel de la
culture du sport et des secteurs liés
qui ne sont pas fermées
administrativement
ja qui ont une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires de plus de 50% bénéficieront
d'une égalité également de cette
indemnisation mensuelle pouvant aller
jusqu'à dix mille euros
toutes les autres entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés là encore subissant une
perte d'achat d'affaires de moins de
plus de 50% bénéficieront d'une aide
pouvant aller jusqu'à 1500 euros par
mois
j'ai évoqué le fait que le click and
collect ne seraient pas pris en compte
dans le chiffre d'affaires
et que donc on pouvait faire du bénéfice
supplémentaire
je veux également cité la suppression
des cotisations sociales toutes les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
fermée administrativement bénéficieront
d'une suppression totale
de leurs cotisations sociales toutes les
pme des secteurs du tourisme de
l'événementiel de la culture du sport
des secteurs liés qui reste ouvert mais
auront perdu 50 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires auront droit à la suppression
de leurs cotisations sociales patronales
et salariales pour tous les travailleurs
indépendants
les prélèvements sont automatiquement
suspendu ils n'auront aucune démarche à
faire et les travailleurs indépendants
fermée administrativement bénéficiant
d'exonérations total de leurs charges
sociales je rappelle que le pg le prêt
garanti par l'état peut désormais être
contracté jusqu'au 30 juin 2021 au lieu
du 31 décembre 2020 et que l'état pourra
accorder des prêts directs si certaines
entreprises ne trouvent aucune solution
de financement
enfin sur la question des loyers tout
bailleur qui sur les trois mois
d'octobre novembre et décembre acceptent
de renoncer au moins un mois de loyer
pourra bénéficier d'un crédit d'impôt de
30% du montant des loyers abandonné ce
qui fait une mobilisation massive de 15
milliards d'euros par mois avec dams et
messieurs les sénateurs pour faire en
sorte d'accompagner le petit commerce
dans la difficulté
merci la parole est à notre collègue
éric bocquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues à l'évidence mesdames et
messieurs les ministres la pandémie due
qu'aux vide 19 n'a pas les mêmes
conséquences économiques pour les
multinationales du numérique et des
petits commerces de proximité prenons le
cas du géant amazon ne fait jamais
l'écart entre les petits commerces et
ses géants technologiques n'aura été
aussi grand vous avez cité quelques
chiffres sony je vais en donner d'autres
les records de valorisation s'enchaînent
à wall street qui connaît des hausses de
10 20 et 50 milliards de dollars à la
bourse depuis le 1er janvier 1000 2020
la valeur d'amazon a crû de 73 6 pour
cent pour atteindre le chiffre
astronomique de 1650 milliards de
dollars l'équivalent du pib de la russie
excusez du peu
la fermeture imposée aux commerces de
proximité va encore aggraver une
situation de concurrence déloyale
mais l'autre scandale réside dans les
pratiques fiscales d'amazon qui ont été
décrites comme les plus agressives des
entreprises du numérique
grâce à des montages savant illégaux
accordé par nos amis du luxembourg près
des trois quarts des bénéfices d'amazon
ne subissent aucune imposition
cette situation est tout à fait
inacceptable plus encore au moment où
les états manquent de moyens financiers
pour faire face aux conséquences
dramatiques de la pandémie
monsieur le ministre il est urgent de
mener une bataille au plan international
pour taxer enfin effectivement les
gaffes à au premier trimestre de cette
année
les rentes d'amazon ont augmenté de 26%
nous proposons qu'une disposition soit
adopté dès le budget 2010 21 en
discussion au parlement en ce moment
visant à instituer une taxe
exceptionnelle sur les bénéfices
d'amazon les fonds ainsi récoltés
viendrait alimenter un plan des
d'urgence au commerce impacté et
notamment aux librairies indépendantes
je conclurai mon propos avec ce mot de
victor hugo la lumière est dans le livre
ouvrez le livre tout grand laissez-le
rayonner laissez le faire
c'est le secrétaire d'état fédrigo
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bocquet je crois
que nous nous rejoignons absolument sur
un point celui de la juste taxation des
entreprises du numérique et c'est
pourquoi vous le savez la france a été à
l'initiative des discussions au niveau
ocde et est leader sur la question de la
taxation des entreprises du numérique au
niveau européen et a par ailleurs
introduit elle même sa propre taxe dite
sur les services numériques
nous avions décaler le recouvrement de
ces taxes pour donner une chance aux
négociations internationales
celles ci n'ont pas abouti je vous
confirme que le recouvrement 2020 aura
bien lieu il faut néanmoins que nous
continuons à pousser ce sujet au niveau
européen parce que c'est le bon niveau
et je veux me réjouir avec vous que
l'europe est annoncée il y a quelques
semaines que face à l'échec des
négociations au niveau ocde elle allait
reprendre cette question de la taxation
du numérique au niveau de l'union
européenne pour faire en sorte que ces
entreprises payent la juste taxation
qu'elle doive afin de contribuer à la
solidarité nationale
mais si la parole de notre collègue
nicole duranton pour le groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
le 13 octobre dernier vous annonciez
avec le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin un appel à candidatures pour
recruter 30 sous préfet à la relance
pour accompagner les citoyens les élus
et les entreprises dans le cadre du plan
de relance national pour faire face à
l'épidémie du comique 19,9 sous préfet
seront affectés en région 18 ans
département 3 en outremer il est prévu
que leur entrée en fonction des buts en
ce mois de novembre et qu'il devienne
pleinement opérationnel début janvier
alors que nous débutons l'examen des
crédits du projet de loi de finances
pour 2021
je tiens à saluer cette initiative
visant à mieux piloter l'ensemble des
dispositifs mis en oeuvre par le
gouvernement
vous décrivez l'objectif de cette
mission prioritaire faire remonter tous
les blocages administratifs
des procédures et des dispositifs
souvent compliqué rencontré sur le
territoire le plan relance france
comporte trois grands volets 30
milliards d'euros pour la transition
écologique 34 pour la compétitivité et
la souveraineté économique et 36 pour la
cohésion sociale et territoriale
ces hauts fonctionnaires s'assureront
que ce plan de relance de 100 milliards
sur deux ans se concrétise
bien sûr le terrain c'est-à-dire
permettent de reconstruire le tissu
économique local
l'attractivité de nos territoires et le
maillage territorial de l'état il s'agit
de renforcer l'efficacité de l'état dans
les territoires et accompagner au mieux
les élus et les acteurs territoriaux qui
oeuvrent déjà au quotidien pour mettre
en place ces mesures de relance loin
d'une conception jacobine de l'état les
collectivités territoriales sont au
coeur de ce plan en effet il faut
réarmer nos territoires pour que l'état
soit un acteur de proximité qui répond
au mieux aux problématiques de nos
concitoyens madame la ministre
quels indicateurs ont été mis en place
pour choisir les départements dans
lesquels seront déployés les sous
préfets à la relance
quels sont les critères de réussite de
leur mission et où en est-on de leurs
déploiements je vous remercie pour vos
répondre la parole et qu'allah bénisse
de la formation et de la fonction
publique - vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice permettez moi de vous
féliciter de vous remercier pour cette
question parce qu'effectivement
effectivement il n'ya pas de relance 100
simplifications et il ne peut pas y
avoir de simplification si nous ne
partons pas du terrain nous ne ferons
pas la relance depuis paris nous la
ferons pas à terme 2 milliards nous la
ferons au plus près des besoins des
français là où ils vivent et c'est
pourquoi le premier ministre a souhaité
que dans chaque département il y ait un
chef de projet de la relance un sous
préfet à la relance pour moi un sous
préfet parce que vous le savez très bien
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est sous préfet réunissent chaque jour
les élus les chefs d'entreprise tous les
acteurs bref ils prennent des décisions
de bon ni au bon niveau et il nous aide
à avancer
à l'heure du second confinement nous
n'avons pas le droit à l'erreur
et l'état dans tous les territoires a
besoin de renforts c'est trop de
candidatures que nous avons ouverte nous
allons fait sur la demande des préfets
de région sur la demande et préfère
département pour appuyer les territoires
qui ont le plus besoin
nous avons donc ouvert ces candidatures
pour créer des interlocuteurs de
confiance partout dans le pays qui
doivent associer les parlementaires les
élus les acteurs
alors nous avons ouvert ses candidats
sion avec demi de l'intérieur trente
postes ont été appelés à être pourvus
ils viennent donc s'ajouter dans les
autres départements au sous-préfet
existants qui deviendront ses sous
préfet à la relance il y en a bien sûr
de votre département dans l'eure il y en
a dans tout notre pays et vous pourrez
monsieur le sénateur donat la sénatrice
évidemment les rencontrer et travailler
avec eux nous avons reçu 200
candidatures de très bon niveau
deux fonctionnaires de l'état mais aussi
territoriaux et c'est nouveau de
salariés du secteur privé
ils seront déployés opérationnel en
janvier aucun territoire et j'en prends
l'engagement devant vous ne sera bien
sûr oublier ses sous préfet je crois il
témoigne plus largement de la volonté
que nous avons entre le premier ministre
de réarmer les territoires que tous les
postes en 2021 soit créé dans les
territoires et pas paris
tout ceci sous la stabilité générale du
schéma d'emploi mais que notre priorité
c'est bien que ce soit dans le dernier
kilomètre au plus près du terrain
partout en france que les milliards que
vous votez devienne une réalité je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la présidente
catherine de roche pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adressait au
ministre olivier ferrand et je
souhaitais aborder la question des
déprogrammations chirurgicale lors de la
première vague le plan blanc nationale a
entraîné en effet des pertes de chance
puisqu'il ya eu des retards de
diagnostic des retards de prise en
charge thérapeutique et je pense
notamment des pathologies comme le
cancer mais aussi à des pathologies
cardiovasculaires par exemple donc nous
sommes maintenant à une reprise des
déprogrammations je voudrais savoir
quelle est la stratégie du ministère
quels sont les qui décide de quoi qui
décide du caractère non urgents des
interventions et quelle est la place de
l'équipe médicale
dans la décision et pouvez vous nous
donner la capacité actuelle des lits
opérationnels en à la fois en
hospitalisation privée et publique qui
justifierait expliquerait sa
déprogrammation
les patients sont très inquiets mais
aussi les médecins de cette situation
pour vous répondre
la parole est aux secrétaires d'état
chargés de l'enfance et des familles
monsieur adrien plaqué merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la madame la présidente
je vous prie tout d'abord d'excuser
l'absence d'olivier vers ans qui se
trouve devant vos collègues députés pour
la commission d' enquête liée commission
denquête liés à la gestion de la crise
duco vite votre question sur la
déprogrammation d'interventions
chirurgicales renvoie évidemment à cet
impératif pour notre système de santé de
continuer à assurer les soins
réanimation pour les patients qui sont
atteints du coc vide ou qu'ils ne le
soient pas et le ministre véran dès le
28 octobre dernier a défini cette
stratégie dont vous demander des
précisions de ma part et que je vais
vous vous détailler la déprogrammation
d'un certain nombre de soins à l'hôpital
notamment d'interventions chirurgicales
non urgentes et un des leviers vous le
savez mobiliser pour garantir cette
continuité de prise en charge avec comme
objectif bien évidemment très racée
déprogrammation de laisser plus de place
à des prises en charge en réanimation
alors les détails cette méthode je
l'évoquais ont été fixées par le
ministre dans un courrier du 28 octobre
derniers méthode qui a été généralisé à
l'ensemble du territoire avec le
déclenchement des premiers paliers de
déprogrammation et du plan blanc pour
libérer des lits dans les régions les
plus attention toutes les activités
chirurgicales y compris ambulatoire et
médicales pouvant l'être doivent ainsi
être déprogrammée dès lors qu'elle
mobilise des ressources humaines qui
peuvent être mobilisés dans les services
co vide
l'hospitalisation à domicile par
ailleurs les sorties précoces et le
télésuivi sont également appelés à être
favorisée par les différents services et
dans tous les cas
évidemment comme de coutume les
déprogrammations restent décidés
décision collégiale soutenue par d
analyse bénéfices/risques de chaque
situation
quand elles sont décidées
elles le sont toutes en garantissant que
les patients atteints d'un certain
nombre de pathologies qui ont été
définis comme comme prioritaires en
quelque sorte par le ministre je parle
du cancer j'parle des attentes des
patients en attente de greffe
les patients suivis pour maladie
chronique et requérant des soins urgents
ou encore des patients pris en charge en
santé mentale
je me permets d'insister sûr ce point
puisse être soigné dans les meilleures
conditions possibles voici madame la
présidente les principes qui guident les
déprogrammations que vous évoquiez
journée madame la présidente
oui merci monsieur le ministre en effet
vous a expliqué la stratégie ce que vous
n'avez pas vraiment expliquer c'est
quelle était la place pour la décision
soit administrative des ars soit
vraiment de l'équipe médicale mais bon
je comprends que c'était peut-être une
question très très précises sur ce point
là ce qui est clair c'est que les
associations de patients sont en effet
inquiètes parce que il y a des
déprogrammations il ya déjà eu des
déprogrammations en début d'année et un
moment il ya eu un espoir parce qu'ils
avaient été définis qu' il y avait une
préparation qui était faite qu'il y
avait des retours d'expérience de la
première vague et que pratiquement n'y
avait pas d'inquiétude à avoir certes
l'épidémie repart et loin de moi l'idée
de la minimiser en effet on souhaite que
tout se passe bien mais comprenez que
pour des patients c'est une douche
froide de 6h certes les interventions
bien aussi beaucoup d'interventions
connexes en matière de cancer par
exemple de prise en compte de la
fertilité d'examens diagnostiques
d'autres examens et qu'ils ne seront pas
dans le caractère d'urgence mais qui
auront des conséquences non négligeables
merci
la parole est à notre collègue monique
lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des milliers de français vont
être plongés dans la pauvreté dans les
semaines qui viennent
nous savons que l'état fait un effort
conséquent pour accompagner nombre
d'entre eux et certaines professions
arrive aujourd'hui à se faire entendre
mais demeurent ceux que j'appelle les
invisibles
je pense aux extras aux permis tant aux
bénéficiaires de contrats à durée
déterminée d' usage
je parle des guides conférenciers des
maîtres d'hôtel des cuisiniers des
livreurs des serveurs des hôtesses des
chauffeurs des agents d'entretien et de
sécurité de tous ceux que je ne peux pas
citer ce sont près d'un million deux
cent mille salariés
typiquement ce qui était menacée par la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui pour
certains ont été pardon je me suis perdu
ce qui était menacée par la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui pour certaines
ont été abandonnés depuis mars 2019 et
qui pour d'autres vivent sous la menace
de cette réforme
vous avez reporté l'entrée en vigueur de
ces mesures pour ceux qui sont privés
d'emploi depuis le 1er août
mais la spécificité de leur travail pour
certains saisonniers fait qu'ils n'ont
pas pu reprendre leur activité à cause
du premier confinement ils n'ont donc
pas pu recharger leurs droits du fait de
cette réforme et se trouve sans solution
si ce n'est celle des minima sociaux
quant aux autres ils subiront forcément
de plein fouet les effets de ces
dispositions puisque étant dans
l'impossibilité de travailler
actuellement ils n'auront donc aucun
droit à recharger monsieur le ministre
je viens de le dire
nous parlons là de plus d'un million de
personnes qui appellent au secours et
que personne n'entend je vous pose donc
deux questions allez vous consentir à
travailler sur une solution de type
année blanche
comme pour les intermittents du
spectacle qui permettra d'attribuer à
ces extras est permis tant un revenu de
substitution
allez vous enfin annoncé la suppression
de votre réforme de l'assurance chômage
pour vous répondre la parole dès lors
aux maîtres qui traverse secrétaire
d'état chargé des retraites et de la
santé au travail avait la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices madame la
sénatrice monique lubin
merci d'abord d'avoir reconnu le travail
et l'engagement du gouvernement pour
protéger les plus vulnérables les plus
modestes dans notre société aujourd'hui
face à la crise sanitaire
vous avez raison cette crise sanitaire
et qui effectivement est suivi de cette
crise économique et sociale a un impact
sur les plus précaires vous en avez cité
un certain nombre et vous avez souliers
on pourrait dire ou moin lé secteur des
hôtels cafés restaurants du commerce
d'ailleurs ce sont souvent dans ces
secteurs que se font les premiers
emplois 25% de ces secteurs trouve
permettent à nos jeunes de trouver un
premier emploi
c'est vrai qu'il y à une progression du
nombre de chômeurs de catégorie a plus
367 1000 entre le début de la crise
sanitaire et maintenant même si le
rythme soutenu de l'activité économique
notamment au troisième trimestre a
permis de faire dégonfler une partie de
ce chiffre qui est difficile je voudrais
vous rappeler à la sénatrice quand même
des éléments qui sont mis en place par
le gouvernement qui ont été aussi
annoncé récemment par le premier
ministre le 24 octobre dans le cadre du
plan pauvreté
je ne vais pas énumérer tout cela je
crois que vous le connaissez bien mais
je voulais quand même souligner
l'engagement du gouvernement avec un
budget de plus de 8 milliards pour
lutter contre la pauvreté et les
nouvelles mesures qui ont été annoncées
le 24 octobre représente plus de 1,8
milliard alors sur le fond vous
m'interrogez sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et la façon dont
chacun pourra acquérir de droits vous
avez souligné que cette transformation
structurelle de notre système
d'indemnisation chômage a été repoussée
jeu
voulais aussi vous rappeler qu'il y a de
concertation qui est menée actuellement
par madame la ministre du travail et
cette concertation
évidemment elles portent sur la
nécessité de couvrir au mieux l'ensemble
de ses salariés qui sont ceux de la
perdre huit ans que vous avez évoquées
et donc ça fait partie des sujets qui
sont travaillés parce que le
gouvernement est particulièrement
attentif à la situation de ces
françaises et de ces français je vous
remercie
dames les bains quelques secondes juste
pour dire monsieur le président que à
monsieur le ministre que vraiment vous
m'avez répondu globalement oui je le
répète personne ne s'intéresse à ce que
j'ai nommé volontairement parce que
personne ne parle jamais d'eux donc nous
attendons une réponse concrète merci la
parole est à notre collègue laurent
duplomb pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre
quoi qu'il en coûte vous avez base et la
totalité de la gestion de cette crise
sur le seul critère éviter la saturation
des hôpitaux en mars 2020 la france
disposait de 5000 lits de réanimation
que j'appellerai standard 4 car au plus
fort de la première vague 7800 lits de
réanimation ont été ouverts en ajoutant
des lieux supplémentaires en ayant
choisi comme seuls paramètres de gestion
de cette épidémie
l'engorgement des hôpitaux pourquoi les
leçons de la première vague ne vous ont
pas servi
et pourquoi des lits de réanimation
n'ont pas été ouverts en nombre
suffisant depuis le 1er confinement
le ministre de la santé durant l'été
lors de son audition au sénat
annonçait plus de douze mille lits
opérationnels pour une éventuelle
deuxième vague
quelle a été ma surprise est sûrement
celle des français qui vous écoute
lorsque vous monsieur le premier
ministre il y a quelques jours annoncé
que le nombre de lits avaient augmenté
augmentaient oui mais à seulement cinq
mille huit cents lits alors monsieur le
premier ministre
où sont les 6200 les mannequins pour
arriver à douze mille lits
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'enfance
et des familles monsieur paquet merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur votre question est l'occasion
de clarifier d'y répondre je vous
confirme et de de clarifier un certain
nombre de choses que semble-t-il vous
n'auriez pas perçu ou peut-être fait
semblant de ne pas percevoir est en tout
cas l'occasion de faire le point sur la
situation des services de réanimation
qui sont fortement mobilisés dans la
gestion de cette crise et que je me
permets puisque vous ne l'avez fait à
saluer l'engagement qui est qui est le
leur alors hier hier c'était 3878 de nos
concitoyens patients qu'aux vite qu'ils
étaient prises en charge en réanimation
cela représente d'ores et déjà monsieur
le sénateur 76,2 5% de nos capacités de
prise en charge en réanimation de nos
capacités initiales basé sur
effectivement c'est 5100 lit que vous
évoquiez juste à titre de comparaison
avant de répondre à votre question
sachez que ce niveau est l'équivalent de
celui de la dernière semaine de mars
alors il est donc impératif vous le
comprenez bien que nous puissions
continuer à prendre en charge les
besoins en réanimation qu'il soit que
vides ou non d'ailleurs
et c'est pourquoi nous agissons sur deux
leviers la déprogrammation nous l'avons
évoqué avec la sénatrice avec la
présidente des roches à l'instant mais
aussi la mobilisation d'autres lits et
donc je ne peux que m'élever en faux
contre les propos que vous avez tenus
oui dès l'été nous avons monté à 5800
c'est le chiffre que vous avez donné le
nombre de lits de réanimation mais la
semaine dernière nous avons atteint 6
1400 lits et nous visons pour la fin de
semaine à pallier à 7700 lit le prochain
palier que nous sommes en mesure de
mobiliser monsieur le sénateur est fixé
à 10 mille cinq cents lits en
réanimation et sachez que les ars
soutiennent par ailleurs les
coopérations entre établissements et les
transferts vers d'autres régions
même si on sait que lors de cette
seconde vad ça va être plus compliqué
puisque l'ensemble du territoire
national et toucher la même façon mais
aussi des transferts vers des pays
étrangers et enfin monsieur le sénateur
vous le savez les lits ne suffisent pas
le matériel ne suffit pas il faut aussi
des
depuis le début de la crise nous avons
formé sept mille professionnels de santé
pour pouvoir agir dans les services de
réanimation et je veux ici saluer leur
engagement
celle du plomb monsieur le ministre
la vérité est que vous avez échoué
échoué à court et à créer ces lits
préférant vous réfugier derrière une
administration française
englué dans ses certitudes et sa
technocratie où tout est impossible
où sont les 10000 respirateur commandés
dont la moitié se sont révélés
inopérants
où sont les 7000 personnel soignant
supplémentaires dont vous venez
d'annoncer annoncé aussi par le
président de la république
gacko dernier pourquoi aucun lien est
fait entre les hôpitaux publics et les
cliniques privées
la vérité monsieur le premier ministre
et que si vous aviez bien gérer l'après
première vague nous n'aurions pas
connaître un deuxième confinement et je
ne peux accepter qu'à cause de votre
entêtement nous en connaissions croyez
moi un troisième un quatrième est
peut-être à 5e
la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente valérie létard pour le groupe
de l'union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues
notre pays d orgue grave en même temps
que les attentats et la pandémie c'est
la crise économique et sociale qu'il
nous faut combattre la pauvreté montrent
de plus en plus de français bascule dans
la précarité et après le travail c'est
la perte du logement qui inquiète
pourrais-je payer mon loyer pourrais-je
loger ma famille et mes enfants
voilà les questions qui nous sont posées
nous parlementaires de terrain dans ce
domaine aussi nos compatriotes ont
besoin d'être rassurés et protégés
monsieur le premier ministre
comme la sécurité sociale le logement
est particulièrement le 1% logement
devenu action logement fait partie du
pacte social que nous avons hérité de la
résistance et de l'après guerre cet
héritage est le fruit d'une triple
volonté volonté de garantir et
sanctuariser chaque année des moyens
financiers au logement y compris dans
les périodes difficiles volonté ensuite
de gérer ces sommes de manière paritaire
entre patrons et salariés volonté enfin
de mener des actions complémentaires à
celles de l'état dans un esprit de
responsabilité sociale pour tous les
français à commencer par les plus
modestes ce modèle ce n'est pas quelque
chose du passé qui sous des prétextes
techniques devraient être abandonnées
c'est un modèle pour aujourd'hui un
modèle d'union nationale pour une france
qui donne ses chances à chacun dans le
modèle on le moment historique que nous
vivons monsieur le premier ministre
quelles sont les intentions de votre
gouvernement en matière de logement et
en particulier à l'égard d'action
logement piliers de notre modèle social
pour vous répondre la parole et madame
bérengère rabat secrétaire d'état en
charge de la biodiversité
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'état action logement est un
partenaire majeur du gouvernement dans
la mise en oeuvre des politiques du
logement
vous savez il s'agit du principal
financeur de l'anru notamment et ses
filiales assure 40% de la production
annuelle de logements sociaux
le partenariat état et action logement
est donc essentiel comme l'a montré la
récente extension de l'aide aux impayés
de loyer pour les salariés modestes le
gouvernement n'a donc aucunement
l'intention de déstabiliser cet
organisme est de diminuer sa capacité de
soutien au secteur du logement
pour autant il paraît important de
moderniser le fonctionnement et la
gouvernance de ce groupe tout en
maintenant sa gestion paritaire la
réforme entamée en 2016 n'a pas été mené
à son terme et il demeure aujourd'hui
d'importants dysfonctionnements
d'organisation et d'exécution
cette réforme permettra également de
clarifier la répartition des rôles entre
l'état et action logement et d'améliorer
la lisibilité et l'efficience des
interventions qui sont déployés à
destination des citoyens et des
entreprises
vous le savez le gouvernement privilégie
la concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux pour définir des évolutions et
mettre en oeuvre et contractualisés ces
évolutions
cette concertation à la d'ores et déjà
débuté d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux seront reçus dès
demain par elisabeth bornes
emmanuelle wargon et olivier du soft ces
discussions elles ont vocation à aboutir
au printemps 2021
elles doivent permettre d'améliorer
cette cette gouvernance de
contractualiser une trajectoire
quinquennal qui soit ambitieuse en terme
d'intervention et d'investissement alors
si la trésorerie de d'action logement
est structurellement bénéficiaire c'est
bien l'utilisation optimale de la
participation de l'employeur à l'effort
de construction qui est recherchée afin
qu'elle bénéficie le mieux possible à la
politique du logement et aux salariés
dans les jours qui viennent le
gouvernement déposera un amendement au
projet de loi de finances afin de
l'autoriser à légiférer par ordonnances
pour permettre d'apporter les
modifications législatives qui seraient
rendues nécessaires par le
l'issue de cette concertation donc soyez
assurés de la pérennité de cette
structure
madame la présidente je voudrais
rappeler à chacun qu action logement
c'est le quasi unique financeur du
logement en france
donc il s'agit pas d'une petite affaire
parce qu'il est lors de la relance du
bâtiment de la construction de la
rénovation
parce qu'il est l'heure d'être au
rendez-vous de la mobilité des salariés
parce qu'il est l'heure d'être là pour
accompagner les impayés de loyer qui
pourrait menacer plus d'un million de
ces français qui peuvent être en
difficulté économique
pour toutes ces raisons est-ce qu'on
peut aujourd'hui objectivement remettra
en question accès au logement remettre
trois ans pour mettre la machine en
route parce qu'on veut la réforme et au
moment où on doit accélérer la machine
être aux côtés d' action logement
il lui permettre d'être efficace tous
ensemble monsieur le premier ministre
connaît votre intérêt porté sur le sujet
on compte sur vous pour que ce ne soit
un passage en force mais une coopération
avec les acteurs du logement le
parlement les élus locaux pour que ce
soit notre affaire collective etc ont
gagné cette bataille du logement et
n'ont pas récupéré de l'argent pour
mettre dans le pot commun au moment où
on sait bien que ce sujet va être majeur
la parole est à d'autres collègues
vincent segouin pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la question que je vais poser
n'est pas la mienne mais celle de
centaines de personnes élus locaux
commerçants indépendants que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir au téléphone ces
derniers jours tous je dis bien tous
sont dans une situation désespérée qui
nous promet rien de bon pour leurs
activités et via parfois au drame
plusieurs maires m'ont parlé de cas de
détresse psychologique chez les
commerçants de leur commune comme ce
restaurateur de 62 ans à la veille d'une
retraite paisible qui a dû réinjecter
les pagnes de toute une vie dans son
entreprise il n'a plus rien et sera mis
en liquidation car incapable de
rembourser ses engagements ce
restaurateur a dû être internée in
extremis par le maire de sa commune à la
suite d'une détresse psychologique
alors même si je suis conscient de la
gravité de la crise sanitaire
on ne peut opposer les mordus kovy
d'aubord économique vous imposer ce
confinement à des commerçants qui n'ont
fait que respecter les mesures que vous
leur aviez imposées
aucune preuve n'a dit que ces commerces
sont des lieux de clusters alors
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple
qu allez vous enfin faire pour que nos
entreprises puissent reprendre leurs
activités au plus vite
monsieur cédric au bourg et pau merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur peut-être revenir
un peu plus en détails sur les éléments
que vous évoquez et partager quelques
considérations rappeler d'abord à
l'endroit de la situation dramatique que
vous évoquez les aides mises à
disposition pour le gouvernement et que
j'ai détaillé tout à leur rappeler
également que oui nous assumons qu'il y
ait un primat du sanitaire dans la
gestion de la crise cela étant dit et le
premier ministre l'a rappelé et le
premier ministre et bruno le maire ont
fait en sorte que certaines choses qui
n'étaient pas autorisés pendant le
premier confinement le soit dans celui
ci pour pouvoir continuer à produire et
à vivre les décisions qui ont été prises
évidemment conduisent à des effets de
périmètre
terrible lié au fait que certains
vendent en même temps de la nourriture
est par exemple des articles 2
d'habillement ce qui a conduit
d'ailleurs et le premier ministre et
bonal au maire a annoncé la fermeture
dans les hypermarchés d'un certain
nombre de régions il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'alternatives monsieur le sénateur soit
continuer à prendre ce genre de
décisions difficiles en dentelle qui ont
des conséquences lorsqu'on ferme les
rayons de certains hypers vous aurez
noté en termes d'emploi absolument
importante
ou alors considérer qu'il faut niveler
égalisé par le bas et c'est à dire par
capillarité rouvrir tous les commerces
et donc mécaniquement mécaniquement
augmenter nos interactions sociales
augmenter le nombre de personnes dans la
rue on peut le soutenir mais en tout cas
cela me paraît assez loin de la réalité
sanitaire de notre pays du fait qu'il ya
un français qui est contaminée toutes
les deux minutes toutes les quatre
secondes
un français qui meurent pendant toutes
les deux secondes un français qui meurt
toutes les 4 minutes et il nous faut
toujours trouver cette ligne de crête
entre la réalité sanitaire la nécessité
de faire respecter le confinement au
maximum et le soutien aux petits
commerces monsieur se voit ministre je
vous le dis clairement vos mesures ne
sont à la hauteur ni des attentes ni de
la situation vous promettez 10000 euros
par entreprise
mais peu auront cette somme vous
souhaitez élargir le click and collect
pour les commerces c'est le contraire de
leur adn vous annoncer des suppressions
de charges sociales ce ne sont que des
reports vous n'avez aucune stratégie
vous recourez sans cesse à la dette mais
la dette est un poison monsieur le
ministre
comme le disait notre président de la
république la dette c'est de l'impôt au
carré puis plus je vous écoute plus je
suis désespéré par votre manque de
cohérence
on laisse ouvertes les grandes surfaces
mais en même temps on ferme des petits
commerces qui pourtant respectent les
mesures sanitaires on ferme nos
restaurants mais en même temps on laisse
ouvert les restaurants d'entreprises ou
des cantines à grande fréquentation on
empêche les gens d'aller chez le
libraire mais en même temps on les
laisse sa masse et dans les transports
en commun on interdit les coiffeurs de
missiles mais en même temps on autorise
les livraisons ou les travaux à domicile
on laisse les gens passer des frontières
dans notre pays sans aucun contrôle
et en même temps on enferme les français
chez eux en les obligeant de justifier
leurs moindres faits et gestes
je comprends les français qui
n'acceptent plus aux injections mais qui
demandent juste de l'écouté et de la
concertation
des mesures sont acceptés canton
surprise et cohérente
vous n'avez plus la confiance du sénat
vous n'avez plus la confiance des maires
sur le terrain et d'agressivité de vos
propos contre est débutée encore hier
ont renforcé cette perte de confiance
la parole est à notre collègue rémi
féraud
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
alors que le terrorisme djihadiste
frappe à nouveau notre pays et l'europe
le président erdogan multiplie les
menaces contre la france comme il
l'avait d'ailleurs fait ces derniers
mois contre le gouvernement autrichien
sa politique impérialiste manifeste en
méditerranée en libye syrie idrac est
désormais dans le caucase où il soutient
concrètement l'offensive de
l'azerbaïdjan contre l'arménie
nous soutenons la position claire et
ferme du président de la république non
pas contre le peuple turc à qui nous
exprimons notre solidarité après le
tremblement de terre d'izmir mais contre
un pouvoir autoritaire qui menacent la
stabilité dans la tête de la région et
la sécurité de l'europe alors même qu'il
est membre de l'otan
alors monsieur le ministre il faut
maintenant que les actes soit la hauteur
des paroles
la france va-t-elle vraiment demandé des
sanctions financières contre la turquie
alors que son processus d'adhésion à
l'union européenne est au point mort
père soit elle encore des fonds de
préadhésion le boycott des produits
français se fait en violation de l'union
douanière entre l'europe et la turquie
s'ils perduraient êtes vous prêt à
demander sa suspension
en septembre un rapport de l'onu dévoilé
les exactions très graves commises à
l'encontre des kurdes de syrie qu'elle
suit envisagez vous de lui donner
comptez vous saisir le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies pouvez-vous
d'ailleurs nous garantir qu'il n'y a
plus aucune vente de matériel militaire
de la france à la turquie
enfin
après la nécessaire dissolution de
l'organisation extrémiste des loups gris
comptez-vous résolument agir contre l'
influence du régime turc sur notre
territoire national pour vous répondre
la parole les communistes de l'europe
des affaires étrangères monsieur jean
yves le drian vers la parole oui
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur rémi
féraud vous posez été question légitime
est totalement pertinente nous avons
avec ankara une longue liste des
désaccords très sérieux et nous
attendons d'abord d'ankara vous l'avez
dit qu'elle cesse son comportement que
la turquie cesse son comportement
belliqueux dans le voisinage européen
les actions unilatérales de la turquie
en méditerranée orientale la politique
agressive de la turquie en libye la
politique de la de la turquie dans le
haut-karabakh son déferrement de
déstabilisation majeure
mais monsieur le sénateur ces dernières
semaines nous avons franchi dans nos
relations avec la turquie un palier
inadmissible entre pays alliés les
insultes les calomnies la volonté d'un
si une campagne de haine à l'égard de la
france et de l'europe sont de nature
totalement différente ce sont des
menaces
nous attendons donc que le président en
turquie son gouvernement mettent un
terme immédiat à ces comportements et
nous ne tolérerons pas non plus que
cette haine cette violence soit exportée
sur le territoire français en étant
relayées par des groupuscules qui ne
doivent pas avoir le droit de cité et je
vais vous dire aussi que les réactions
unanimes de solidarité de toute l'europe
démontre que ce n'est pas uniquement une
question de contentieux franco turque
mais d' attaque contre l'europe ses
valeurs son modèle de liberté
fondamentale et d'état de droit et je
voudrais rappeler qu'il ya un rendez
vous monsieur le sénateur posées par le
conseil européen au mois d'octobre avant
même l'escaladent que j'ai constaté que
vous avez constaté le rendez vous c'est
si la turquie ne modifie pas
fondamentalement sa posture et
concrètement sa posture avant le conseil
européen de décembre
alors nous prendrons les mesures
nécessaires au niveau européen
l'encontre des autorités
vous avez proposé une liste est dans
cette position position du rendez vous
de décembre dois vous dire ici que
toutes les options sont sur la table
monsieurbureau merci monsieur le
ministre nous avions alerté au moment de
l'invasion d'afrique dans le nord de la
syrie sur les risques d'être faible face
aux entreprises du président et yoann je
crois que la suite l'a démontré nous
souhaitons et nous serons vigilants sur
la fermeté dans les mots et dans les
actes de votre gouvernement je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
pascal allizard pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
ces dernières années les désordres
géopolitiques mondiaux puis la crise
sanitaire ont remis sur le devant du
débat public le concept de souveraineté
qu'elle soit nationale voire même
européenne contrairement à d'autres
secteurs largement délocalisé les
industries de défense française continue
à produire en france et pèse dans notre
économie
engagé au service de la sécurité
collective
elle représente un vivier de compétences
rares et d'emploi dans les territoires
cette excellence permet à nos armées de
disposer de la meilleure technologie
possible pour conserver la supériorité
sur le terrain elle est aussi bénéfique
au commerce extérieur en permettant de
rivaliser à l'export avec les pays à bas
coûts vre pour autant le secteur de la
défense n'est pas exempt de fragilité et
les confinements de l'année 2020 vont
laisser des traces
les entreprise française de technologie
vous le savez suscite déjà des
convoitises
certaines sont passés sous contrôle
étranger
j'avais aussi évoqué le cas de photos
nice l'un des leaders mondiaux de la
vision nocturne qui après maintes
péripéties intervention de l'état serait
néanmoins rachetée par un groupe
américain
monsieur le ministre alors que le
gouvernement brandit par tout le concept
de souveraineté contenant comment pardon
comptez-vous mieux protéger les
entreprises de la bd française leur
permettent de se financer pour assurer
leur développement
une solution française pour photo ni son
nom vouloir émerger le gouvernement
sera-t-il au rendez-vous pour faire
aboutir cette solution pour vous
répondre la parole et
tôt secrétaire d'état chargé de la
transition numérique des communications
électroniques
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur sur la question de l'entreprise
telle est d'amener de son projet de
racheter l'entreprise photonis vous
l'avez dit l'entreprise chez les dames a
soumis une demande d'autorisation pour
acheter l'entreprise photo nice en début
d'année 2020 au titre du processus des
contrôles d'investissements étrangers en
france
photonis là encore vous l'avez dit est
une entreprise qui fournit des
entreprises du secteur de la défense
française et qui dispose de technologies
de pointe notamment en matière de vision
nocturne comme la loi le prévoit dans le
cadre de la procédure de contrôle des
investissements étrangers en france le
gouvernement et notamment les services
de bruno le maire instruit l'offre de
télé down et a posé un certain nombre de
conditions à une éventuelle décision
d'autorisation de cet investissement
notre position monsieur le sénateur a
toujours été clair il faut protéger nos
entreprises stratégiques et leur
technologie mais il faut aussi rendre
possible des investissements nécessaires
au développement des entreprises en
question notamment pour continuer de
garantir qu'elle reste à la pointe de
leur secteur c'est cet objectif que nous
avons poursuivi dans le cadre de nos
analyses de l'opération photonis à la
suite des échanges que nous avons eus
avec l'entreprise télé down cette
entreprise a fait le choix de retirer
son offre de rachat de photos nice il
existe un certain nombre de solutions
mais si télé deine devait soumettre une
nouvelle demande d'autorisation de
rachat de photos ni au titre du contrôle
le f
alors l'état l'analysera à la lumière
des conditions qui avaient été posées
lors de la première négociation et avec
le même objectif celui de concilier la
défense de notre souveraineté
technologique avec le développement
nécessaire de notre industrie de défense
thual izard
chez le ministre malgré les éléments que
vous venez de rappeler photo nice sera
rachetée par un groupe américain qui en
outre a joué des exigences françaises
que vous venez de rappeler pour revoir
son prix d'acquisition à la baisse c'est
en tout cas et vous le savez la
communication tonique de l'acquéreur
teledyne plus que de la communication ou
du coup par coup
nous attendons des actes forts pour la
souveraineté
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue élisabeth doineau pour le
groupe de l'union centriste j'avais la
parole le sait le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la santé des
solidarités je la partage avec mon
collègue claude kern qui a été le
premier à m'interpeller sur le sujet ma
question porte sur le risque de pénurie
de sang un risque lié tout autant aux
difficultés actuelles de collecte cas la
non revalorisation des personnels de
l'établissement français du sang côté
collecte nous avons besoin de dix mille
dons par jour pour satisfaire aux soins
d'un million de malades chaque année or
la crise sanitaire entrave
considérablement la collecte moins de
dons de la part des étudiants qui figure
parmi les populations les plus
généreuses en la matière moins de
personnel dans les entreprises ou aux
lieux le nombre de collectes des
professionnels de le ffs qui sont aussi
touchés par le virus et des bonnets et
des bénévoles empêché pour cause de
vulnérabilité et pour ne rien arranger
l'engorgement des hôpitaux duala
qu'ovide impose des déprogrammations et
ensuite des reprogrammations
d'opérations qui augmente les besoins
dans ces conditions le fs tire la
sonnette d'alarmé
le stock est en grande tension le
problème entre en résonance avec celui
du personnel de le f s alors que le
gouvernement annonce l'accélération de
la revalorisation des salaires des
professionnels de santé des hôpitaux et
des ehpad publics pourquoi avoir exclu
du ségur les professionnels de santé qui
travaillent à l'établissement français
du sang 1000 m
1500 à 2000 infirmières et infirmiers
des techniciens de laboratoire
ressentent aujourd'hui une véritable
forme d'injustice
eux aussi ils sont au fond depuis
longtemps et plus encore depuis la crise
sanitaire
monsieur le ministre allez-vous
revaloriser le statut des personnels de
l'efs s et comment comptez vous agir et
réagir pour assurer les besoins en stop
de poches de sang et de leur gestion
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'enfance
des familles monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice élisabeth doineau dans la
lignée delà de la question de la
présidente des roches votre question
rappelle très justement qu'en cette
période de crise de sanitaires des
opérations indispensables qui ne
relèvent pas de l'épidémie doivent
continuer à avoir lieu c'est le cas de
celle évidemment qui implique des
transfusions sanguines et qui donc que
repose sur ce don régulier de sang de
plaquettes ou ou de plasma je pense
notamment à la prise en charge des
effets de certaines pathologies longue
durée comme le cancer ou les maladies
dues les maladies du sang alors vous
l'avez évoqué la reprise du confinement
pour vous répondre sur cet aspect de
votre question a pu susciter un certain
nombre d'inquiétudes les restrictions
des déplacements au strict nécessaire a
en effet un impact sur la mobilisation
en matière de dons notamment parce que
depuis toujours 80% des dons reçus par
le ffs proviennent de la collecte mobile
en particulier vous l'avez évoqué dans
les écoles dans les entreprises ou sur
les campus universitaires
or depuis le mois de mars ces lieux
accueillent beaucoup moins de collecte
et le ffs a s'est efforcé de palier de
compenser ses difficultés notamment en
élargissant ses plages horaires mais
nous sommes néanmoins vous l'avez
rappelé tombé fin septembre un niveau de
poches de globules rouges aux réserves
que nous n'avions plus connus depuis dix
ans pour autant enfin c'est la raison
pour laquelle tout du moins que nous
avons lancé un appel aux dons qui avait
été fortement relayée et je tiens à vous
partager le point de situation suivant
cet appel aux dons a porté ses fruits le
stock de concentré de globules rouges
qu'on appelle les cgr au 3 novembre est
bon avec 113 1000 unités en stock soit
18 jours de réserves calculée sur les
données prévisionnelles il n'y a pas par
ailleurs difficulté
répertorié sur le groupe 0 - les
donneurs universels
le prélèvement par ailleurs est à la
baisse par rapport aux trois semaines
précédentes mais reste dans les
prévisions que nous avions élaboré le
besoin est en net recul de près de 11%
sur la semaine écoulée et enfin
troisième élément le stock de plaquettes
les stocks de plaquettes sont bons on
comptait plus de 1500 concentré de
plaquettes hier en fin de matinée ouais
je veux donc vous rassurer et rassurer
la représentation nationale sur le fait
qu'il n'y a pas de source d'inquiétude à
ce jour nous devons néanmoins rester
tous mobilisés monsieur le président si
vous me permettez de conclure cette
séquence de questions au gouvernement
par cet appel aux sénateurs et aux
français qui nous écoutent prendre une
heure pour donner son sang c'est
permettre de sauver 3 vies
il faut donc continuer à donner son sang
pour les françaises jouent très bien
nous nous associons à cet appel
merci monsieur le premier ministre nomme
des messieurs les ministres
je vous rappelle que nos prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu jeudi
12 novembre à 15h la science bêtasse
suspendu et sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen d'une convention internationale
qui vont la procédure simplifiée notre
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà donc pour cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
une séance consacrée majoritairement
principalement à la situation des petits
commerces en cette période de
confinement alors on a senti
l'inquiétude des sénateurs une
inquiétude sur une possible distorsions
de concurrence entre les petits
commerces et la grande distribution une
dit possibles distorsions entre ces
petits commerces et le géant américain
amazon sur la forme ce qu'il faut noter
c'est l'absence de bruno learn bruno le
maire sur le banc des ministres du coup
c'est cédric au qui a répondu aux
questions des sénateurs aux questions
sensibles portant sur les petits
commerces
la socialiste laurence harribey a vu
dans l'absence de bruno le maire et dans
les réponses de cédric au un nouveau
manque de respect il parlement écoutez
vous avez l'art de déformer les propos
et le fait que ce soit vous qui
répondiez est très significatif du
respect du parlement parce qu'il est
impossible d'aller d'état d'urgence en
état d'urgence sans concertation
modifions la gouvernance de cette crise
en s'appuyant sur le père le parlement
plutôt qu'en lui donnant la leçon commis
hier soir à l'assemblée nationale
voilà autre thème du jour les attentats
commis sur le sol français quelle
réponse le gouvernement doit y ait
apporté ici la droite à nouveau fait le
lien entre immigration et terrorisme
réponse de jean castex les terroristes
qui s'en prennent à ni ne sont pas
toujours des étrangers pas de nécessité
donc d'agir sur les flux migratoires
jean castex qui a rappelé que le texte
sur les séparatistes sur les
séparatismes sera présenté début
décembre en conseil des ministres merci
merci beaucoup steve pour toutes ces
explications et tout de suite on prend
la direction de la salle des conférences
où se trouvait alexandre plus tard pour
les premières réactions et celle d'abord
d'hervé marseille président du groupe
union centriste au sénat
et oui avec marseille on va parler et
bien de la fermeture des commerces non
essentiels un sujet qui a marqué cette
séance de questions d'actualité
les sénateurs sont assez remonté à
propos de cette fermeture des commerces
non essentiel pendant le confinement
mais hervé marseille ce que vous
comprenez le gouvernement
qui dit il est avant tout une urgence
sanitaire et il faut fermer les
commerces oui il ya une urgence
sanitaire tout le monde la reconnaît
mais c'est pas une raison pour faire
n'importe quoi
je pense que le sénat qui représente les
territoires est très attentif à la
situation des villes et villages de
france et on peut pas faire la même
politique dans une grande ville et dans
ce qu'on appelle les territoires on peut
pas avoir la même politique à l'égard du
e-commerce et à l'égard de petits
commerces il faut voir que sur les 36000
communes de france il y en a la moitié
qui ont moins de 500 habitants
songez à tous ces petits commerces qui
sont le coeur de la france qui bat au
quotidien qui fait le tissu social et le
sénat avait adopté il ya quelques jours
un amendement à l'unanimité pour
permettre au préfet d'avoir délégation
pour ouvrir lé préfet c'est pour ouvrir
les commerces sélectivement dans tel ou
tel village en fonction du besoin et de
l'intérêt donc on peut avoir une
politique plus fine tout en étant
j'allais dire attentif à la santé de nos
concitoyens
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la réponse
du gouvernement dans cette polémique
avec bruno le maire qui parle des maires
irresponsables qui ont autorisé à ouvrir
les commerces
le premier ministre jean castex qui a
parlé par exemple hier des élus qui
encourage à violer les lois de la
république
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette fois
sur dur je pense qu'il faut que le
premier ministre comme le gouvernement
soit un peu moins nerveux et puis soit
plus respectueux peuvent pas passer leur
temps à dire que les élus sont
formidables que les maires sont des gens
avec lesquels il faut travailler parce
qu'ils sont en proximité de la
population qui doivent travailler que
les préfet puis en même temps passé leur
temps à dire que sont des gens
irresponsables et qui font n'importe
quoi
merci beaucoup hervé marseille pour
votre réaction après cette séance de
questions d'actualité
merci beaucoup alexandrins pour cette
réaction d'hervé marseille et vous allez
également avoir à votre micro patrick
kanner c'est lui le président du groupe
socialiste
ici au sénat mais oui avec patrick
kanner pour parler d'abord et bien du
sujet polémique
cet après midi en séance de questions
d'actualité la fermeture des commerces
de proximité pendant le confinement le
gouvernement invoque l'urgence sanitaire
c'est quand même une décision
rationnelle c'est évident que la
situation est très mauvaise sur le plan
sanitaires la vraie question qui nous
est posée est ce que la fermeture des
commerces et les petits commerces qui
sont très sécurisé enfin chacun a pu le
tester à titre personnel était la bonne
mesure le gouvernement persiste et signe
c'est son droit le plus strict mais ça
n'enlève rien malheureusement aux
incohérences quand on voit les images
aujourd'hui de ces bâches qui sont mis
dans les grandes surfaces pour empêcher
les français finalement est bien de
faire leurs courses
comment peut-on faire la partition entre
les que le commerce est essentielle ce
qu'il ne serait pas en tant que tel
c'est une forme de rationnement qui est
en train de se mettre en place dans
notre pays je crois qu'il faut le le
regretter et les mesures de prohibition
ne marche jamais elles finissent
toujours par être contournée est donc
sacré surtout un climat d'angoissé dans
notre pays patrick kanner je voudrais
vous entendre sur l es différent quoi
qui ont eu lieu hier dans le pilotage de
cette crise sanitaire d'abord avec un
couvre-feu annoncé à paris mais démentie
par matignon et puis ensuite à
l'assemblée nationale hier soir des
députés la république en marche pas
assez nombreux et finalement
l'opposition qui fait passer des
amendements pour renforcer le contrôle
du parlement qui se faisaient penser de
cette séquence
c'est une très mauvaise séquence pour le
gouvernement qui navigue à vue et quand
je vous dis ça je n'ai pas envie de
tirer sur l'ambulance gouvernementale
parce que finalement nous sommes tous
sur le même bateau
dans cette crise sanitaire par contre ce
dont nous avons besoin c'est quand même
voilà un gouvernement premier ministre
qui fixe le cap et qui permettent aux
français de se projeter
je pense que la solidarité autour de
cette idée d'unité nationale n'est pas
un vain mot on est prêt à le faire mais
à condition que les choses soient
claires et si vous avez un gouvernement
qui n'est pas à la hauteur de sa tâche
parce qu'il a des propos très
contradictoires de d'un jour à l'autre
voire même d'une heure à l'autre
et bien cela crée un trouble chez les
français merci beaucoup patrick kanner
d'avoir répondu à mes questions c'est à
vous tous merci merci beaucoup alexandre
c'est la fin de ce débrief vous l'avez
entendu les commerces de proximité mais
aussi l'état d'urgence sanitaire sont au
coeur des préoccupations des sénateurs
tout de suite et bien olivier véran est
auditionné devant la commission denquête
de l'assemblée
nationale vous allez pouvoir suivre cela
en direct en intégralité chez nos
confrères de lcp
nous on se retrouve exceptionnellement
la semaine prochaine jeudi le 12
novembre à 15 heures pour la prochaine
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
très bonne soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]